[Musique]
Pierre connaî ça. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succinement ?
Euh je suis de formation historia. Euh
puis ensuite,
j'ai passé l'ENA, j'ai travaillé une
trentaine d'années dans les la haute
administration et puis les 10 dernières
années de ma vie professionnelle à
dirigé une société intelligence
économique. Maintenant, je suis
retraité. Donc, je me livre
essentiellement à de l'écriture et de
l'analyse. Voilà
le c'est tout ce que je peux dire.
Votre parole est donc libre ?
Ma parole est libre. Le problème, c'est
qu'elle l'était aussi quand j'étais
dedans, si vous voulez, ce qui m'a
effectivement créé des enduis. Mais
c'est un peu le paradoxe qu'on va
essayer de développer, c'est-à-dire
quand vous êtes dans une structure
et beaucoup d'amis du Korblondi, on est
obligé d'adopter la culture de la
l'organisation à laquelle on appartient.
Et donc le
on peut pas dire par exemple à un
ministre, vous savez tout le monde se
fout de la position de la France dans le
pays où je suis affecté. Il faut
toujours lui dire le l'ensemble de nos
partenaires attendent une prise de
position du département et cetera.
C'est à moitié caricatural. Une fois, je
me suis amusé à écrire un télégramme
diplomatique sans objet. Pourquoi ?
Parce que si vous voulez, l'argumentaire
était toujours un peu le même.
C'est-à-dire, il faut montrer que la
France est une puissance importante,
payer des droits de l'homme, puissance
nucléaire, membre permanent du conseil
de sécurité. Puis à partir, on peut
raconter ce qu'on veut parce qu'il faut
donner au pouvoir central l'impression
qu'effectivement la France est un acteur
essentiel sur tout théâtre de crise quel
qu'il soit, y compris les problèmes
d'alimentation en eau au tout àou quoi,
quelque chose comme ça. Donc
cette distance critique, ça suppose de
se déconnecter d'une administration si
on renonce à faire carrière. Voilà, donc
on arrête là, c'est pas la peine d'aller
plus loin.
Alors aujourd'hui, on va parler guerre.
Comment on arrive à la guerre ? va
parler peut-être renseignement,
intelligence économique, sanction
et autres joyauseté inhérente à la
guerre. Euh première question.
Alors
moi ce qui m'a motivé sur la guerre,
c'est que et ce qui continue d'ailleurs
motiver, c'est comment se fait-il qu'on
aboutisse à quelque chose qui est assez
extraordinaire ? Parce que la guerre,
c'est une inversion des valeurs
habituelles de la société.
Il faut tuer. On a obligation de tuer.
Si on refuse de tuer, on est tué par ses
compatriotes. Donc déjà cette inversion
de valeur là, pour qu'elle soit
acceptée, il faut qu'il y ait tout un
processus qui amène les gens dans les
démocraties comme dans les dictatures,
dire à considérer que c'est un processus
impossible à éviter.
Et deuxième question pour l'avoir vécu
de l'intérieur au ministère de la
défense, je m'élève et encore plus
aujourd'hui, bien que ce soit difficile
à expliquer, contre l'idée que j'entends
souvent, c'est que les démocraties sont
pacifistes et les dictatures sont
bellicistes, ce qui est complètement
faux parce que on y reviendra, mais la
France et la Grande-Bretagne sont été
les deux grandes puissances, les deux
Républiques ou les deux démocraties du
19e et du 20e siècle et elles étaient
les deux grandes puissances coloniales
de la planète. Bon, quand en 1948, on
vote le la charte internationale des
droits de l'homme, on a donc les deux
puissances coloniales France et
Grande-Bretagne dans les membres
permanents. On a les États-Unis qui sont
racistes et ségrégationnistes. On a la
Russie de Staline et on a la Chine de
Changai Cheek. Donc en matière de droit
international, il faut bien penser que
c'est en gros faites ce que je dis,
faites pas ce que je fais. Bon,
ça c'est important. On reparlera du du
droit international. Oui, mais alors
justement, c'est pour ça que le droit de
la guerre est une espèce de trou
intellectuel, c'est-à-dire comment
est-ce qu'on fait que au bout d'un
certain temps deux populations qui ne se
connaissent pas vont aller se massacrer
pour deux au bénéfice de deux chefs qui
parfois eux-mêmes se connaissent et et
se respectent. Alors
ça c'est un c'est un point qui est
encore une fois très important, c'est
les démocraties ne sont pas pacifistes
par nature. Depuis 91, on a fait donc
chute de l'URSS,
on a mené une trentaine d'opérations
d'OPEx d'opération militaires
extérieures. Alors évidemment après le
11 septembre alors là c'est
l'éclatement, c'est la folie absolue.
Mais tout ça parce que encore une fois
il y a une une universitaire qui a
utilisé le terme de des guerres justes,
entre guillemets. C'est-à-dire qu'à
chaque fois, il fallait trouver une
justification à quelque chose qui
pouvait être purement et simplement une
agression scénario irakien
mais qui fait que derrière tout ça vous
avez un certain nombre de courants
idéologiques qui expliquent que cette
guerre est juste. Alors après il faut
trouver
parce qu'ils apportent la démocratie
pour les populations, parce qu'ils
apportent les écoles pour les petites
filles, parce qu'ils font arrêter les
bombardements, parce qu'il protègent
d'un génocide.
Ben, c'est-à-dire que là, on va glisser
sur quelque chose d'autre qui est une
caractéristique qu'on voit bien
aujourd'hui.
Mais juste revenant sur ce ce qu'ont été
des décisions officielles, c'est-à-dire
que
après le 11 septembre, tout à coup
apparaissent dans les motivations de la
guerre que sont les néoconservateurs
américains qui ont beaucoup de d'affidés
en France et les néovangéliques
américains. Alors, ce qui est
intéressant, c'est la double démarche
parce que les les néoconservateurs
proches d'Israël considèrent que la
disparition de Saddam Hussein
alors qu'on est dans le 11 septembre, il
avait rien à voir le pauvre Saddam,
hein. Bon, c'est à sa disparition, on va
contribuer à la stabilité d'Israël. Et
les néo évangéliques, ce qui est très
intéressant, c'est qu'ils sont très
proches des né des néos des radicaux
juifs. C'est-à-dire qu'il considèrent
que la constitution du grand Israël, tel
que promis dans la Bible, est la
condition d'arrivée du Messie.
Alors, il s'est passé une anecdote que
qu'il faut que vos auditeurs
connaissent. Donc, évidemment Netaniaou
les choyer comme on pouvait très bien
imaginer, mais enfin ça posé un problème
théologique de base, c'est que pour les
juifs, vous savez bien que le Messie
n'est jamais venu, tandis que pour les
chrétiens, il est déjà arrivé. Donc, il
y avait des discussions oiseuses sur le
thème le Messie et cetera. Et alors, un
jour, Nethaniaous s'en est sorti en
disant "Écoutez, le jour où il viendra,
on lui posera une seule question. Est-ce
que c'est la première fois ou est-ce que
c'est la deuxième fois que vous venez
Bon comme ça, hop, il a arrêté la
conversation. Mais on a des motivations
qu'on éétudie pas ou qu'on croit étudier
avec des motivations stratégiques parce
que en faisant c il va faire ça et
cetera. Les ressorts profonds qui vont
mener à la guerre et je prends
volontairement l'exemple d'une
démocratie, ce sont des ressorts
profonds qui vont se donner une
légitimité et dans lequel c'est pas la
recherche du pétrole qui va
conditionner. Il il y a évidemment le
pétrole, c'est-à-dire qu'évidemment ils
vut mieux s'emparer de l'Irak que de
s'emparer du du Yémen. Mais il reste que
euh le la motivation idéologique pour
que la chose apparaisse acceptable par
une démocratie ne sont pas on va on va
capter le pétrole irakien.
Donc ce qui m'a intéressé
c'est justement de comprendre comment on
arrive aux guerres et comment on y
arrive évidemment surtout par les les
démocraties.
C'est c'est on y arrive. Pourquoi ?
parce que il y a une carence en terme de
renseignement. Il y a il y a un biais un
biais de confirmation, pas de biais de
confirmation. Il y a de l'idéologie dans
les S tank. Les S tank ne voient rien.
Les services de renseignement ne voient
rien. Ils veulent pas écouter.
On va prendre on va prendre on va
prendre l'exemple russe avec la guerre
en Ukraine.
Ouais. Mais
ça fait ça fait euh euh des années que
les Russes font des exercices militaires
à nos frontières
qui font passer des bombardes des
bombardiers stratégiques à 100 km de
Brest en disant "Coucou, on est là." Ils
font passer leur sous-marins, "Coucou,
on est là." Ils font des démonstrations
lors de salon militaire où ils
présentent leur nouvel armement en
disant "Regardez mon gros missile, c'est
le meilleur du monde. Regardez bien,
regardez bien."
Ils font
2 3 4 5 6 7 déclarations.
Ah le soleil est revenu.
C'est pas grave.
On en arrive là à la guerre. les
certains sing tank ont compris qu'il
allait avoir la guerre uniquement quand
ils ont compris quand ils ont vu les
photos satellites de 100000 ou 200000
hommes à la frontière ukrainienne, il
voulit pas le voir. Comment ça se passe
? Est-ce que le Kedorse fait un travail
euh correct à votre avis ? Est-ce que
les services de renseignement informment
correctement nos dirigeants ou est-ce
que nos dirigeants ne veulent pas voir
les choses ? Macron a essayé d'arranger
les choses depuis de de ou 3 ans.
Il faut pas s'imaginer qu'une décision
politique, surtout depuis 91 a
fondamentalement
correspond au critères qui étaient ceux
de la guerre froide. Pourquoi ? parce
que disparaissent disparaît l'ennemi
structurant, le communisme et tout à
coup, il y a une espèce de d'hibrice qui
s'empare de la des pays occidentaux
parce que
première décision de Gorbatchev quand il
a terminé avec l'URSS, c'est la guerre
du golf, il donne son il oppose pas son
véto et on va faire la guerre à Saddam
Hussein pour libérer le Kouit. Qu'est-ce
qu'il y a d'intéressant dans l'épisode ?
que euh
quelqu'un invente l'idée que c'est la 4e
armée du monde. J'ai jamais su qui était
la 3è mais enfin il paraît que c'était
la 4e. Bon et donc on va faire une
guerre qui va mobiliser plein de monde y
compris 150000 soldats américains et qui
va aboutir à une guerre en 120h. C'est
court ça. C'est d'autant plus court que
toutes les chaînes de télévision du
monde sont là et que pour la première
fois on va vivre une guerre en live.
Bon, donc évidemment, on sort de cet
épisode avec l'idée que on a mandaté
pour être les gendarmes de la planète.
Et à partir de ce moment-là, le le
complexe militar-intellectuel dont
j'essaierai de parler tout à l'heure va
dire là, il y a une crise, il faut y
aller parce que il y a une menace de
génocide, il y a une crise humanitaire
et c'est à ça. Exemple symbolique la la
Somalie. la Somalie. Donc à un moment,
on apprend dans les journaux que il y a
des chefs de bande qui pillent des
convois humanitaires alors qu'il y a la
famine et cetera et cetera. Je ferai
remarqué que la Somalie exportait du
grain en Arabie Saoudite mais enfin
c'est pas grave. Donc ce qui est
important c'est la dramatisation. Alors
la dramatisation c'est de dire
effectivement il faut absolument arrêter
ça. Donc il faut envoyer non pas de
l'humanitaire mais des soldats pour
protéger l'humanitaire. ce que les
humanitaires détestent parce qu'ils
disent notre condition d'exercice c'est
que justement on ne nous prenne pas
comme un partenaire dans la guerre de
l'un ou de l'autre côté ou
un service de renseignement déguisé.
Oui. Ou un service de renseignement.
Mais bon, en même temps, en matière de
renseignement, la Somalie, ça nous
apportait pas grand-chose, hein. Bon,
donc
intéressant. Euh j'en parle avec Rony
Broman, patron de MSF, qui me raconte
comment il a vécu cette intervention
somalienne.
Il me dit, "J'appelle mes équipes à
Mogadicio en leur disant qu'est-ce qui
se passe ? Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
?"
Les équipes lui disent écoute, les types
qui volent les convois ne sont pas des
les types qui pilent les convois ne sont
pas des voleurs. Ils ne revendent pas la
nourriture. Il la distribué à leur clan
parce qu'ils estiment qu'ils sont mal
servis.
Ils ont pas augmenté le flux.
Bah alors justement, ils disent si on
augmente le flux, on tue une des une des
causes de la conflictualité.
Donc Broman prend son bâton de pèlerin,
il va à Bruxelles à New York et pendant
qu'il est là-bas, hop, la guerre est
déclenchée par un autre humanitaire qui
s'appelle Kouchner mais qui lui est
devenu un politique. Vous voyez ce que
Pourquoi vous dites qu'il a déclenché la
guerre ? Pourquoi vous dites qu'il a
déclenché la guerre Kouchnière ?
Mais parce que il était devenu
politique, il était plus humanitaire.
Or, un politique qui déclenche une
guerre par principe de dire, il a
l'impression d'être dans sa fonction. Tu
sais,
je me rappelle plus bien comment il a
fait pour déclencher cette guerre là. Il
a jamais déclenché cette guerre. Ben,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait tout
l'arrière-fond intellectuel. On disait
comment ces gens qui meurent de faim
machin, on peut pas laisser faire et
cetera. C'est-à-dire, tu vois
l'interpellation
sur le thème on ne peut pas ne pas la
double négation permet de dire il faut
absolument puis en militairement c'est
pas grand-chose donc on y va. L'erreur
du militairement négligeable est très
intéressante parce que ça va expliquer
tous les autres interventions par la
suite. Et donc on envoie des militaires,
les Américains sollent aussi. Et puis tu
connais l'histoire, ils veulent
absolument considérer que le grand
méchant loup, c'est le général Iid, le
celui qui tient Mogadicho parce que
c'est lui qui voit l'arrivée des convois
humanitaires par bateau et cetera. Donc
il décide de se débarrasser d'idente, il
connaît Mogadicio mieux que les J
américains et que les services de
renseignement américain. Donc il y a cet
accrochage avec des hélicoptères
américains. Il y a une vingtaine de Jis
qui sont tués. Donc les Américains
disent nous envoyer des boys se faire
tuer pour ces pour les Africains. C'est
fini, on se retire. C'est pas le faucon
noir. C'est ça.
C'est ça. C'est l'opération faucon noir.
Exactement. Et donc si tu veux les moi
dans l'opinion publique américaine qui
s'était ému de la question humanitaire
c'est immédiatement ému par le fait que
20 boys sont été tués. En plus les corps
sont traînés dans les rues de
Mogadition. Enfin il y a tout le côté
dédramaturgique si tu veux qui fait que
si c'est comme ça, on s'en va. Donc les
Américains viendront pas au Rwanda. Non
non nous l'Afrique on s'en s'en occupe.
On s'en occupe plus. Donc si tu veux
cette crise là aujourd'hui tout le monde
se fout de ce qui se passe en en
Somalie. Donc soit c'était un problème
stratégique et dans ce cas-là, il
faudrait toujours avoir une politique
somalienne, soit c'était un phénomène
humanitaire et médiatique. Et dans ce
cas-là, ben on dit bah après tout les
les Somaliens, ils peuvent ils peuvent
se tuer entre eux, ça ne nous concerne
plus. Donc tu vois que le rapport avec
la guerre froide est complètement
différent parce qu'à l'époque de la
guerre froide, si on négligeait une
crise, on avait le risque que l'URSS
l'instrumentalise. Tandis que là, on se
dit "Bon, on fait cela B cela, ils voent
pas de nous, c'est pas grave." Bon, donc
si tu veux, on commence un nouveau
rapport à la guerre parce que l'épisode
du Katwait
a montré que la supériorité des armées
occidentales était telle que on va
souvent avoir la solution d'envoyer du
militaire en pensant que ça va calmer
tout le monde. Bon, on a une première
des convenu à à Sarayevo. On met des
forces françaises et anglaises en
interposition en se disant ils vont se
tenir tranquilles. On a perdu, je crois,
plus de 80 types en Yougoslavie quand
même. Donc on était dans une position de
porte à fond. On croyait que le simple
présence de casque, quelle que soit la
couleur suffisait. Et puis alors
surtout, on va avoir à partir de du 11
septembre une espèce de déchaînement
absolu parce que autant on a considéré
que la décennie était une espèce de
décennie où finalement il y avait plus
d'ennemis, que les Russes ne se
manifestaient plus. Donc on pouvait
faire de l'humanitaire, on pouvait faire
du soutien à tout problème à droite à
gauche. À partir du 11 septembre, on
voit tout à coup apparaître un ennemi
que personne n'a vu arriver. Personne.
Là, je reviens sur tes questions de
renseignement, c'est que Ben Laden, on
le connaissait, il avait déjà exprimé un
certain nombre de mécontentements en
particulier quand se se déclenchait la
guerre du Kit, il était allé voir le roi
d'Arabie Saoudite en disant "Mais moi,
j'ai des troupes que j'ai et aguéri qui
rentre d'Afghanistan. On peut défendre
la patrie des lieux par des musulmans.
Et le roi lu dit, "Attendez, on est
entre gens sérieux, on va s'adresser aux
Américains." Et les Américains vont
débarquer, 150000 hommes qui vont
débarquer dans les rues de de toutes les
villes américaines, de toutes les villes
saoudiennes avec des femmes qui
conduisent, avec des femmes qui foutent
la raclé à la police religieuse quand
elles ve ils veulent leur donner des
ordres et cetera. Donc c'est un profond
séisme dans la société saoudienne. Mais
en même temps la guerre est gagnée très
vite. Bon simplement Ben Laden y a gardé
son sa dent contre à la fois la
monarchie et contre les Américains et
finalement il va donc commencer les
attentats en Arabie Saoudite y compris
sur des compares Américains et les
Américains vont se déménager pour aller
au Qatar. Mais tu vois bien que à partir
de ce moment-là toute la mécanique se
dérègle. C'est-à-dire que on a euh un
type qu'on connaissait parfaitement,
c'était lui par lequel transitait les
euh l'aide au mujahidine, les vous savez
ce qu'on appelait les combattants de la
liberté. Après, on les a appelé les
talibanes. Enfin bon, on les appelait
les combattants de la liberté. Et donc
on est dans une situation où si tu veux,
on se disait tant que c'était le cadre
est- ouest, on se disait les ennemis de
nos ennemis sont nos amis. Bon là, on
s'aperçoit que tout le logiciel doit
être repensé. Alors, comment est-ce
qu'on se sort de la situation ? Et là,
c'est pour ça que je te dis, c'est pas
une question de service de
renseignement, c'est que 11 septembre
comment on n' pas vu le coup de Poutine
s'énerv.
Oui, mais si tu veux, il faut le prendre
dans la continuité. Je reste une minute
sur le sur la question des services de
renseignement.
Quand après le 11 septembre,
il y a un fait, 15 saoudiens sur 19
terroristes,
plus gros contingent de combattants
étrangers en Afghanistan avec les
combattants de la liberté. Donc tu te
dis un fait, c'est pas une question de
renseignement, c'est un fait l'Arabie
Saoudite a contribué à la diffusion du
salafisme sur la planète. Donc la
question de l'aveuglement du politique
n'est pas une question d'information,
c'est une question de posture politique,
diplomatique, tout ce que tu veux. Et
ça, on va le retrouver à l'égard de la
Russie puisque évidemment ton sujet
c'est celui-là. Pourquoi je dis ça ?
Parce que
quand tout à coup se provoque ce séisme
de la disparition de l'UR RSS,
séisme pour les Russes
pour tout le monde pour tout le monde
parce que évidemment dissolution du parc
de Varsovie. Donc la question se pose
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de la Russie ?
Léger flashback. Tu te souviens qu'on a
fait deux guerres mondiales au 20e
siècle. On les a résolu. On en est sorti
à chaque fois avec des méthodes
différentes. Guerre de 141. Bon, c'est
vrai que la guerre s'était passée en
France, mais on a dit l'Allemagne
payera. Effectivement, l'Allemagne a
payé, elle a eu la crise terrible et
puis solution Hitler.
Deuxème guerre mondiale, on a décidé, on
reconstruit y compris avec l'ennemi avec
grâce à l'aide des Américains. Tu vois
bien que à l'égard de la Russie qui
disparaît en 91, on a pris la première
posture. La Russie doit payer, elle nous
a fait tellement de mal, elle nous a
tellement emmerdé et cetera. En plus, on
a tous les pays satellites qui disent
"Ou là là, sortez-nous de tout ce qu'on
a vécu pendant 50 ans." Et donc, ils
vont demander tout de suite l'adhésion à
l'Union européenne, l'adhésion à l'OTAN.
Bon, pas de raison de leur leur refuser.
Bien que les Russes déjà considèrent que
dans les entretiens qu'avait Hugorbachev
avec les responsables américains, on
s'était engagé à ne pas élargir
l'automne puisqu'on ne voulait pas la
dissoudre. C'était une promesse verbale.
Une promesse
c'est une promesse verbale. Mais enfin
si tu veux, si tu penses pas
diplomatiquement aux décisions que tu
prends, tu peux difficilement dire aux
Polonais, vous savez, rassurez-vous,
vous avez pas besoin de l'OTAN. Bon, ils
ont quand même vécu deux fois le partage
ou trois fois le partage de la Pologne.
Ils ont une espèce de tropisme
exactement d'ailleurs comme le tropisme
des Russes. On en parlera. Mais tu
comprends bien que la pression
diplomatique politique était que
effectivement ces pays voulaient entrer
dans l'OTAN. Donc c'était difficile de
leur refuser. Mais on connaît la crise
en Yougoslavie et on va avoir des pays
qu'on va admettre dans l'OTAN et
d'autres qu'on va pas admettre. On va
admettre la Slovénie dans l'OTAN, on va
admettre la Croatie dans l'OTAN, on pas
la Serbie dans l'OTAN, tu vois. Donc on
est capable de faire du sélectif mais
l'idée générale c'était de toute façon
il faut baliser tout autour de la
Russie. Le choc pour les Russes, il faut
quand même le mesurer aussi dans le
temps long.
Dans leur histoire, les Russes, ils ont
été envahis quatre fois. Quatre fois. Et
souvent ils s'en sont sortis auprès de
la politique de la terre brûlée, tu
vois. Donc ça laisse en général le même
si la guerre se termine à leur avantage,
ça laisse en général des des séquelles
très grave envahi par les Polonais, par
les Suédois, par les Polonais, par les
Français, par les Allemands. Donc ils
ont un espèce de complexe ombilical,
c'est que de toute façon toute la
menace, excepté les Mongols, mais ça
c'est autre chose, considère que
l'Europe reste une espèce de menace
perpétuelle comme si l'Europe l' refusé.
Et donc après 91, que ce soit Yelsine,
que ce soit même Poutine, veulent
s'accrocher à l'Europe. Mais avec la
suspicion que j'ai connu dans les
milieux de réflexion stratégique avec le
poids de ces néoconservateurs, c'était
là attention la Russie, on sait pas ce
que c'est et cetera, il vaut mieux les
tenir à distance. Et finalement, on n'
jamais construit
la logique de sécurité qu'on aurait pu
construire à partir de ce moment-là, en
particulier en aidant la Russie dans ces
moments dramatiques qu'elle a vécu dans
les années 92. 93 qui sont très
comparables à ce qu'a vécu l'Allemagne
dans les années 20. Tu te rends compte
que l'économie russe à l'époque, c'était
40 % de l'économie qui était
démonétisée.
C'est-à-dire qu'il fallait que tu ailles
faire tes courses en emportant des
bouteilles vides pour les échanger
contre des pommes de terre. Donc quand
on a connu cette détresse là et queon
sait surtout le pillage que l'époque
Yelsine a autorisé, c'est-à-dire que
tous les oligarques qu'on connaît
maintenant sont des mecs qui ont fait
des fortunes gigantesques
en quelques années. Ils ont ils se sont
accaparés les richesses de la de la
Russie.
Kodorkovski, il était milliardaire à 25
ans. Bon
donc quand arrive un type comme Poutine,
sa double mission c'est de taper sur les
oligarques. C'est en prendre certain en
tout cas Kodorkovski par exemple tout en
s'arrangeant avec les autres. Mais en
tout cas, il va faire comprendre aux
Russes que c'est fini le pillage. Bon,
quand en mettant terme notamment à
certains de ses oligarques, il vont en
prendre une partie pour lui quand même,
il faut pas s'oublier. Mais il il donne
le sentiment au Russes que effectivement
il va y avoir enfin un état qui va
éviter le le pillage. Donc ce type, il a
une certaine assise en Russie. Il a
l'assise du type qui rétablit une forme
de dignité de la de la Russie ancien
empire qui a vu ses frontières reculer
de 2000 km. qui voit éclater 15 États
nouveaux qui étaient ces anciens qui
étaient des anciens composantes de
l'Union soviétique. Et donc il faut le
prendre aussi comme ça. C'est-à-dire ce
type il va plusieurs fois tenter d'abord
de d'essayer qu'on n'intervienne pas.
Voilà juste encore un cadrage important.
Les États fédéraux, ils ont un problème,
c'est quand ils éclatent comme les gens
qui ont vécu à l'époque du fédéralisme
se déplacer à droite à gauche, aller
habiter les Serbes, aller habité en
Croatie, les Russes allaient habiter en
Ukraine et cetera. Quand l'empire éclate
se pose le problème des minorités
dispersées partout. On avait le problème
en Yougoslavie, on l'avait connu. Il y
avait des Serbes qui étaient en Croatie
qui voulaient pas quitter ce qu'on
appelait les Craï et cetera et il
fallait absolument aboutir à la
conclusion que il fallait les les
menacer pour militairement. Là, on se
retrouve en Russie avec un pays qui a
éclaté dans lequel il y a entre 30 et 40
millions de Russes dispersés sur
l'ancien territoire soviétique. Et ces
30 ou 40 millions sont aussi bien dans
les États-Baltes à Kaliningrad, encore
au Kazakhstan et cetera.
Donc on se retrouve face à un problème
qu'on a beaucoup de mal à gérer, c'est
que soit tu considères que ces nouveaux
États indépendants, n'oublie pas que ce
sont des frontières administratives qui
sont des frontières politiques à
l'époque de Staline, tu penses bien la
frontière administrative.
Or, Staline, c'était le fouille merde.
C'était le type qui fallait absolument
qu'il fasse des délimitations
administratives, qui fasse qu'aucune
communauté soit exclusive dans un
territoire donné parce que ça donnait
toujours la possibilité d'intervenir.
Donc dans ce découpage administratif, il
reste tous ces séqueles, tous ces
résidus de population russe et qui vont
tous avoir des postures différentes. On
le voit bien dans le Donbas, ceux-là,
ils disent "Nous, on est russe, c'est
pas parce que la frontière
administrative passait là que on peut
pas rester russe."
Et donc on est face à un problème qui
qui est une contradiction entre deux
principes du droit international,
la souveraineté des États et le droit
des peuples à disposer d'eux-même. Et
selon prend l'un point de vue ou
l'autre, on donne raison au
sécessionnistes, on donne raison au à
l'État central. Donc on est face à cette
situation dans laquelle on peut
comprendre la logique de Poutine disant
d'ailleurs à nous français vous êtes
gênez pas pour aller évacuer vos
ressortissant
et tout le monde d'ailleurs l'a fait
hein. Les Américains pareil le font dans
certains endroits. Donc on sait que on
va le le considérer lui comme le méchant
dans l'affaire ce qu'il est probablement
d'ailleurs le cas mais on reviendra.
Et par contre cette légitimité de la
défense de ces ressortissants à
l'étranger, c'est pas nous français qui
pouvons effectivement le critiquer sur
ce pointl. Donc à ce moment-là, il faut
construire un ennemi
parce que effectivement si tu veux
expliquer que dans les mêmes
circonstances, tu peux pas juger de la
même manière le même comportement, il
faut expliquer que l'autre c'est parce
qu'il est mal il est mal luné, qu'il est
mal intentionné et puis solution
nouvelle si tu veux qu'il est fou. Alors
ça c'est très intéressant parce que
fou fou ou ou malade ? Oui ou fou ou
malade mais c'est l'arrivée des psy si
tu veux dans le débat stratégique
les
leur grande arrivé dans le débat
stratégique c'est le 11 septembre parce
que si tu veux l'ennemi, le terroriste
salafiste Ben Leden est un ennemi qu'on
a tellement peu vu arriver alors que il
y avait les moyens de renseignement, il
y avait des analyses, il y avait tout ce
qu'on voulait euh sauf qu'on ne peut
l'expliquer que par le fait que
l'individu était imprévisible.
Imprévisible ça veut dire fou. Moi. Donc
à ce moment-là, tu vas avoir des tas de
gens sur les plateaux télé pour
expliquer que en fait Benaden tout
petit, j'en sais rien, il était frappé
par son père, par sa mère, j'en sais
rien. On va trouver des tas d'expit et
pour Poutine, on fait exactement pareil.
C'est-à-dire qu'on ne voit pas
l'individu dans sa trajectoire
de nouveaux dirigeants qui essayent de
rétablir une certaine dignité de la
Russie, grande puissance, grand pays,
grande culture, tout ce que tu veux.
Parce que si à un certain moment lui
arrive à la guerre, c'est que
fondamentalement il est fou.
Alors encore une fois, je ce qui est
intéressant, c'est la gamme de la de
l'explication parce que on va l'accuser
de mentir. C'est vrai qu'il ment
d'ailleurs, il dit il ouvre des
négociations en même temps qu'il prépare
son plan de campagne avec cinq axes de
pénétration différents sur l'Ukraine.
Donc c'est pas l'incident de frontière,
il prépare l'invasion.
Et je peux te couper ?
Ouais, vas-y. En
en parlant de préparer l'invasion et en
parlant de préparer la guerre,
on on a remobilé le film. Nous, on
s'intéressait à la Russie depuis à peu
près 2014 2013-24 et on a commencé à se
déployer un peu partout pour savoir
comment il réfléchissaient, comment ils
s'organisaient, comment ils se
communiquaient et ainsi de suite.
On a suivi de de très près les armes,
leurs nouveaux prototypes et on a suivi
aussi leur dédolarisation,
leurs achats de d'or et d'argent,
leur capacité à faire des exercices pour
se déconnecter de l'internet. Hm hm.
Donc on en ar on en arrive à l'hypothèse
que ça fait 8 ans 8 10 ans qu'il
préparent leur coût.
Ouais. Oui. Ça c'est traduit d'ailleurs
par des interventions à la périphérie de
l'URSS. C'est traduit par des
interventions en Geéorgie. Ça c'est
traduit par des interventions en
Moldavie ou des choses comme ça.
C'est-à-dire qu'effectivement
ce que tu dis c'est quel est le projet
géopolitique de Poutine ? dirigeant qui
veut montrer que il rétablit la dignité
et l'honneur de de la Russie, c'est
justement cette logique
interventionniste mais pour le moment
limité enfin jusqu'à l'affaire de Syrie
limitée à la reconstitution de l'ancien
espace soviétique. Évidemment l'Ukraine
c'est le plus gros morceau. Donc on
comprend que celui-là soit celui qui
déclenche la crise. Mais on l'a vu
encore une fois sur des théâtres
périphériques où on s'est dit bon après
tout et la geéorgie veut rentrer dans
l'OTAN. On se dit ouais après tout on
les comprend les pauvres la prasie et
cetera, l'occéti tout ce qu'on veut.
Donc
si tu veux son projet enfin en tout cas
tel que je l'imagine moi, c'est la
reconstitution de la zone d'influence de
l'ancien espace soviétique.
Euh et comme les pays les ex-pays
satellites eux ont carrément ancré leur
présence dans l'OTAN, il faut rendre
compte que l'OTAN depuis 91 a intégré 15
états nouveaux. Combien de vagues ? cinq
vagues
pour l'utant, je me souviens plus très
bien. Il y a eu des il y a eu des vagues
d'adhésion, j'ai pas les dates en tête
mais mais enfin, tu vois bien que à
chaque fois que des diplomates
occidentaux et russes se rencontraient
et en particulier au à la conférence de
Munique il y a 2 3 ans, Poutine a
clairement expliqué que il en avait
marre, que il fallait que ça arrête
quoi. Mais encore une fois, tout dépend
de la façon dont tu prends le discours
d'un type en fonction de ce que tu crois
et de sa puissance réelle. Voilà.
Donc le fait que Poutine a certainement
contribué parce que c'est
fondamentalement un soviétique si tu
veux, c'est-à-dire que la logique de la
force, ça suppose d'avoir des moyens
militaires et c'est vrai que le seul
secteur dans lequel il a profondément
agi, c'est quand même la remise à niveau
de l'armée soviétique.
Il faut se rendre compte que l'armée
soviétique
était présentée
avant l'Afghanistan
comme une espèce de formidable machine
de guerre. Castor Yadis c'est qu'
écrivait des des bouquins entiers sur
l'armée soviétique.
Il y avait un autre qui disait oui
c'était Castor Yadis qui disait l'Union
soviétique ne sait faire que la guerre.
Bon, le problème c'est que effectivement
cette magnifique armée rouge, elle s'est
fait gonfler par des combattants
dépenaillés en Afghanistan et que
surtout les gens qui suivaient la guerre
afghane comme Olivier Ruis se rendit
compte des difficultés de cette
formidable machine de guerre qu'on
croyait imbattable. problème de
logistique, problème de comportement des
hommes, pillage des fois dans des
villages pour voler de la farine. On dit
"Mais attends les types voler de la
farine pour des militaires et parce que
si tu veux la machine de guerre qu'on
croyait totalement huilée, imparable et
cetera avait des problèmes de
logistique, avait des problèmes
d'organisation et cetera et puis surtout
une absence totale de volonté de se
battre." Mec qui était là en
Afghanistan, c'était une armée
d'appelés. Bon donc beaucoup des
faiblesses si tu veux que étaient
constatable à ce moment-là et de
l'humiliation qui consiste en 89 à se
retirer de l'Afghanistan.
Tu comprends bien que dans tout ce monde
politico-militaire,
Poutine avait beau jeu de dire non, il
faut rétablir la dignité de la Russie
passe par la reconstitution de l'efforts
de guerre. Et donc il va faire tout ce
que tu dis est vrai. Simplement la
question c'est est-ce que tu considères
que c'est un seul une posture de défense
ou est-ce que tu considères que c'est
une posture agressive ? Et c'est à
travers l'Ukraine qu'on a effectivement
pour la première fois la question posée
aussi clairement.
Donc
alors si tu veux ce qui est intéressant
c'est le procès qui est actuellement
mené contre Poutine. Donc il ment. C'est
vrai. Il a menti. Il a dit "On va
négocier et cetera alors qu'il préparait
son plan d'invasion. Bon à côté de
George Bouche et Coline Powell, c'est un
gamin, je veux dire Coline. Bah parce
que
pour nos auditeurs qui ne suivent pas
les géopolitiques,
pardon.
Pour nos auditeurs, on va expliquer.
Ah oui oui, bien sûr. Bah si tu veux,
c'est le déclenchement de la guerre en
Irak. C'est-à-dire on va expliquer qu'il
y a des armes de destruction massive en
Irak alors qu'on finit 10 ans
d'embargot. Le plus terrible des
embargos qu'on a jamais installé sur un
pays en Irak depuis 91.
Les enfants mouraient de la rouge parce
qu'on interdisait les médicaments en
plat. On va inventer qu'ils ont des
armes de destruction massive. Alors la
IEA, tous les organismes internationaux
disent "C'est faux, le nucléaire, il a
complètement été démantelé, il y a
rien." Mais donc il va falloir apporter
une preuve indubitable, c'est le
scénario où Coline Powell arrive à
l'assemblée générale de l'ONU avec sa
petite flasque disant voilà là-dedans,
j'ai la preuve que il y a des armes de
développement de destruction massive
développé en Irak.
rappelle-toi qu'il y avait eu le
bombardement d'Alabja, c'est-à-dire
qu'il y avait eu effectivement
l'utilisation d'armes chimiques contre
des populations. Donc Saddam Hussein
était capable avant.
C'était Saddam Hussein ou sous le
commandant de Saddam Husen. Mais c'était
à l'île chimique, c'est ça ?
Oui. Alors là, c'était son
collaborateur. Oui. À l'île chimique.
Donc si tu veux, on va faire une guerre
en mentant. Tu penses bien qu'il y avait
rien dans la fiole de Coline Pawel ?
S'il avait vraiment mis des armes
bactériologiques, l'assemblée générale
de l'ONU, si ça s'était cassé, il
restait plus personne. Donc il y avait
un mensonge qui a été filmé, rendu
public et cetera, mais tout c'est toute
la crédibilité de l'action militaire
occidentale qui tombe d'un coup. et et
les Français le savaient d'ailleurs le
renseignement français a fait
correctement ce que
bien sûr les Français disaient c'est
faux parce qu'on a des gens à la on a
des gens au
l'organisation de contrôle des armes
chimiques et cetera et donc ces gens-là
disaient mais non voilà toutes les
inspections qu'on a fait voilà tous les
sites qu'on a visité et cetera et cetera
donc tu peux toujours dire ouais ouais
mais ils en ont caché un stock
ils ont des camions pour enrichir
ouais c'est ça il y avait l'histoire des
camions et je me souviens mais si tu
veux tu te dis qu'est-ce qui est plus
facile que de casser une arme
bactériologique dans un hôpital
C'est facile. Donc tu peux toujours dire
qu'il y a plein de choses qu'ils ont
caché. Mais enfin, toujours est-il que
tu connais le résultat. Ce résultat, il
est de de deux dans deux dimensions.
La technique de guerre américaine, c'est
la supériorité aérienne permet de
bombarder, de détruire tous les
objectifs stratégiques et puis ensuite
quand l'ennemi est à plat, ben à ce
momentlà il demande la paix. Bon, donc
c'est ce qui s'est passé, les campagnes
aériennes sur l'Irak avec destruction
des centrales de filtration d'eau, les
centrales électriques, les machins
machins machin machin. Et donc quand les
soldats américains débarquent en Irak,
ils disent aux Irakiens euh qui
n'avaient plus ni l'eau, ni
l'électricité, ni la sécurité, ni rien
du tout, ni forces armées et cetera, de
leur dire "Vous avez la chance, vous
avez la démocratie."
Bon, les mecs disaient "Ouais, mais
peut-être mais à l'époque de Saddam
Hussein voilà." Donc, tu vois comment on
tue un projet politique euh avec des
méthodes militaires mais parce que il y
avait cette brise guerrière, on était
tellement convaincu queon pouvait faire
le bien avec de la guerre.
Donc là, là, il s'était affranchi du
droit international.
Ah bon ? Complètement là, il s'était
assis dessus. Je sais pas
est-ce que est-ce que Poutine qui
s'assoit maintenant sur le R
international, c'est parce queil y a eu
un précédent américain.
Ben de toute façon, c'est la logique de
puissance. La logique de puissance, que
ce soit la France en Afrique, que ce
soit les États-Unis en Amérique latine,
que ce soit les Russes dans leur espace
soviétique, c'est toujours
faites ce que je dis pardon.
L'ordre mélien
ou c'est faites ce que je dis, faites
pas ce que je fais. De toute façon, le
motif, il est pas difficile à
construire.
Il est pas très difficile à construire.
Donc il a menti, il a préparé son plan
bien.
Alors oui, donc la première chose, il a
menti. Ensuite il tue. Ça, on envoie
tous les jours un truc. Donc je rappelle
oui, il veut déstabiliser un pays voisin
et cetera comme Saddam Hussein,
il va pas s'arrêter.
Alors après la question effectivement et
c'est là qu'on entre dans la le débat
sur le complexe militaire intellectuel,
c'est tous ces gens qu'on va faire venir
sur des plateaux télé pour leur poser
tous la même question. Et maintenant
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? Alors si tu
veux, tu as une double
les mecs qui n'ont pas vu venir le coup
et on leur on leur
Ah non, tu parles pas d'officiel, moi je
te parle de gens qui sont des
spécialistes de l'islam, des
journalistes, des humanitaires, des
universitaires et cetera. Il y avait
toujours la même question. Qu'est-ce
qu'il va faire maintenant ? Ou à
d'ancien militaire, qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire maintenant ? Personne ne sait ce
qu'il va faire maintenant. Mais si tu
veux, la la pétence qu'on a vis-à-vis
des plateaux télé fait que depuis le
début de la guerre, là on aurait été au
13e ou 14e jour, tu as 90 ou 100
personnes qui se sont succédées sur les
plateaux télé, tous avec des légitimités
partielles ou sérieuses, mais qui à qui
on pose toujours la même question, c'est
qu'il va faire maintenant. Euh moi je
prétends que je ne connais pas Poutine.
Je suis peut-être le seul à pouvoir le
dire et tous les autres ils expliquent
tous qu'ils ont rapport. Alors tu as
parfois des anciens officiers du KGB qui
sortent et qui disent "Moi, je l'ai
connu tout petit dans les collèges et
cetera." Qu'est-ce que tu veux accorder
comme crédit à un type comme ça ? Je
sais pas. Alors, il est filtré par des
services du ministère de la défense qui
sont pas obligatoirement les services de
renseignement mais qui vont être testés
le type en disant qu'est-ce qu'il
raconte ? Est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
accorder crédit à la façon dont il
décrit son propre passé, le passé de la
Russie et cetera ? Mais mais tu vois
bien que on vit tous aujourd'hui dans un
monde où le politique reçoit deux
sources d'information, enfin en vérité
trois. Il a ses moyens propres service
de renseignement, service diplomatique
et cetera. Chacun a sa culture propre.
Mais tu bascules pas un service de
renseignement centré sur l'islamisme
toute faç pour en faire un service de
renseignement centré sur la Russie parce
que tu as recruté des islamologue, tu as
recruté des arabophones et même si la
Russie avait été rétrogradée si tu veux
dans le champ des priorités, tout à coup
elle redevait une priorité. Donc tu vas
pas construire un un système de
renseignement qui tout à coup va te
donner toutes les clés.
C'est
deè chose
c'est ballot.
Pardon ?
C'est Ballot.
Bah c'est Ballot. Si tu veux pas avoir
un service comme la NSA américaine,
regarde la NSA, elle écoutait les les
leaders occidentaux.
Tu te dis "Mais attends, tu croyais pas
qu'ils auraient dû faire plus ?" Parce
que on est dans quelque chose où le
service de renseignement, c'est devenu
un appendice de la politique de
sécurité, de la politique de défense,
mais aussi de la politique économique.
Comment on peut torpiller un gros
contrat qu'on veut gagner pour les
gagner politique américaine. Donc les
types, il faut les prendre pour ce
qu'ils sont. Tu vas pas faire d'un type
du renseignement un spécialiste des
questions financières. tu vas en trouver
dans les banques mais tu vas pas tout à
coup en trouver un qui va être le le
spécialiste de tel J'ouvre une
parenthèse. Dans la parenthèse.
Ouais.
de ton expérience dans les services de
renseignement. Tu as jamais tu es jamais
tombé sur quelqu'un qui s'intéressait à
tout.
Non non c'est pas possible.
C'est avoir un prisme à 362 c'est
Non c'est pas possible. Il faut être
villein ou Vedrine. Tu vas pas les
mettre à la tête de la DGSE. Quand il y
a eu l'affaire du Rainbow Warrior, tu te
souviens ? Première question que je
m'étais posé sur ancienement, je leur
dit mais [__] mais comment vous êtes
arrivé fait des morts et en plus ils
font sauter le bateau dans le port
d'Ackland
tu vois ce que je veux dire et les mecs
avant même qu'ils aient quitté Auckland
déjà la police néerlandaise
néozélandaise les avait arrêté bon tu te
dis donc il y a des mecs qui vivent dans
un monde c'est pas James Bond et James
Bond n'est pas un agent de renseignement
tu vois ce que je veux dire donc on a on
a l'idée que avec des services de
renseignement on sait tout surtout non
les services de renseignement ont des
questions auxquelles ils doivent
répondre il y a des plans national
national de renseignement et évidemment
tu ne mutes pas, tu ne transformes pas
une spécialité très difficile à acquérir
pour faire du renseignement sur un pays
comme l'Irak en un système qui doit te
faire du renseignement sérieux sur la
Russie. Bon donc tu es obligé de
t'appuyer si tu veux sur des
spécialistes que tu vas aller plus avec
qui tu vas aller discuter que tu vas
éventuellement traiter comme honorable
correspondant et cetera mais encore une
fois c'est parfois d'un niveau assez
médiocre. Deuxième remarque, on a vécu
la révolution d'Internet à l'époque de
la guerre froide. C'était ce que les
services de renseignement trouvaient qui
est déterminait le fermer parce que
l'ouvert il y en avait pas. On avait
savait rien sur la Russie. Tout à coup
avec Internet beaucoup de choses sont
accessibles à tout. Donc, il faut
commencer par recenser ce qui est de
l'information ouverte pour ensuite
chercher ce qui est de l'information
fermée. Alors, tu peux toujours dire
"Oui, mais c'est le renseignement, c'est
le militaire, c'est tout ça." Mais ce
que tu dis toi, ce que tu as trouvé avec
tes propres moyens sur les nouvelles
armes russes prouve que tu as pas besoin
d'être dans le renseignement pour ça.
Donc, tu vois la difficulté du métier.
Bon, si tu veux, ils ont les services
officiels
épisode vécu,
on se le qu d'oré, je t'ai dit la
culture c'est quand même si tu veux
faire carrière, faut faire gaffe.
Alors, revenons à nos moutons. Alors,
Poutine a menti. Poutine là, on
continue.
Alors, Poutine a menti et puis
effectivement, il veut
il veut renverser un leader d'un pays en
fait
pour pouvoir en fait mettre un
gouvernement fantoche et cetera. Bon,
c'est exactement ce qu'on a voulu faire
avec Saddam Hussein, hein. N'oubliez
pas, c'est qu'à partir du moment où
Saddam Hussein était renversé, renversé,
on a confié à un mec qui s'appelait
Brenner qui était une brêle complète et
qui a commencé à à casser tout l'État
iraakien et qui a donné les clés aux
chiites. C'est-à-dire que les chiites se
sont vengés de tout ce qu'avait été le
régime de Saddam Hussein. Donc,
conseillé auprès de lui où il a, tu
sais, on a à l'Élysée, on a souvent
utilisé le terme des visiteurs de 10h du
soir. Visiteurs de 10h du soir, c'est
les mecs que les présidents reçoivent
qui genre VHL, tu vois, et qui vont être
les conseillers secrets qui vont leur
dire qui vont leur expliquer le monde.
Ça veut bien dire qu'ils n'ont pas une
confiance absolue, si tu veux dans ce
que leur raconte leur service. Nous, on
a une chance en tant que français, c'est
qu'on a l'agence France-presse.
L'agence France-Press, c'est un
formidable outil, beaucoup plus efficace
que le qued d'ors. C'est pas sa mission.
Sa mission c'est d'informer. Quand tu es
diplomate dans un poste, tu sors pas
s'il y a des manifestations. Si tu te
fais piquer, c'est l'incident
diplomatique. Tu es rapatrié en urgence
au pays, tu emmerdes ton ambassadeur et
cetera. Je te coupe. On a vu quand même
Michel Alomari
au moment des révolutions en Tunisie
prendre l'avion dans un pays en
insurrection pour aller proposer des
technologies de contre-insurrection.
Ah bah bien sûr. Oui,
c'était quand même magnifique ça.
Ah bah c'est prodigieux. Oui, bien sûr.
Pour une ancien ministre de la défense,
je trouve que c'est fort. Mais bon, elle
avait une petite relation avec Ben Ali
qui était pas extrêmement saine. Mais je
te prends l'exemple de Ben Ali parce que
c'est intéressant.
Ben Ali, rappelle-toi, c'était celui qui
avait empêché qui avait assuré la sortie
Bourgiba. Il avait empêché les
islamistes d'arriver et cetera. Donc
c'est un type qui qu'on considérait
comme un dirigeant
qui empêchait la menace principale. Bon
euh
je vais en Tunisie pour tout à fait
autre chose et j'avais un copain qui
était à Lena avec moi, un Tunisien qui
entre-temps avait fait sa carrière
auprès de Banali. Il était secrétaire
général du ministère de la défense.
Ensuite il a été ministre de la défense.
Donc je le vois, je pour demander
rendez-vous, je lu dis mais enfin
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Je sais plus ce qu'il avait décidé
Benall fait un truc complètement
absurde.
J'ai dis mais qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Il est fou. Il me dit non non simplement
il est mal conseillé et cetera. Je dis
attends on se connaît depuis 20 ans, tu
vas pas me sortir le coup du mauvais
conseiller. Il me dit non il a eu un
AVC, il a plus il est plus capable de je
vais à l'ambassade et je leur dis vous
savez Benelli il a eu un AVC.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est-à-dire que tu te dis mais tu peux
pas en tant que la difficulté de dire
des réalités est parfois très difficile
dans ce système là. Par contre les mecs
de la FP avec qui il en a parlé
évidemment il a creusé tout de suite
pour savoir où est-ce que le mec était
soigné, on allait l'amener au Val de
Grâce. Enfin tout ce que tu peux
imaginer. Donc tu vois la difficulté de
l'appréhension d'une situation, c'est
une multiplicité d'approches
et chacun de ses ses systèmes a sa
propre a sa propre méthode de de
d'analyse. Bon donc sur le cas de
Poutine,
rappelle-toi la rétrogradation dont les
soviétologues ont été l'objet après 91.
Ils étaient le haut du panier. Ils
étaient les mecs à qui il fallait poser
des questions sur tout ce que risquaient
de faire les soviétiques au Vietnam en
Cambod, tout ce que tu veux et cetera.
Et en fait brutalement ils sont
remplacés par les islamistes, les
spécialistes du terrorisme, machin et
cetera et cetera. Donc ils ont toujours
entretenu le feu en disant "Non, non
mais en Russie, vous savez
fondamentalement ça reste les mêmes.
Moi, j'en ai connu plein qui
continuaient à dire "Méfiez-vous,
méfiez-vous". Finalement, ils sont
avérés qu'ils avaient raison, mais ils
n'expliquent pas le pourquoi du
processus qui va conduire Poutine à être
ce qu'il est aujourd'hui. Tu vois, il a
symboliser ce que je crois être la
réalité en en Russie, c'est-à-dire c'est
le type qui a rétabli la dignité. Alors
après, quand le type devient fou, c'est
un peu le processus benali, c'estàdire
c'est un démocrate quand il prend le
pouvoir et puis ensuite si tu veux, il
joue le jeu de se faire réel lire,
rélire, de se faire remplacer, de
remplacer ensuite le remplaçant du
remplaçant enfin tout le truc qu'il a
fait avec Medvedf. Et là, tu t'aperçois
qu'à ce moment-là, comme disait
Saint-Just, le pouvoir rend fout et le
pouvoir absolu fout absolument.
Bon, donc il y a eu un processus, c'est
ça qui m'intéresse, c'est ce processus
là. C'est-à-dire à quel moment il faut
sonner des comment dire tirer sur la
sonnette d'alarme de façon à ce que non
seulement t les renseignements
militaires,
chose qui est du domaine du
renseignement de la DRM et cetera, qui
était probablement évalué correctement.
La France est le seul pays qui a des
moyens de renseignement sérieux si tu
veux en Europe hein. Le reste est
dépendant des renseignements américains.
Mais et donc probablement, enfin je suis
j'étais pas à l'Élysée, mais
probablement les militaires ont tiré la
sonnette d'alarme en disant "C'est
étrange, il y a des mouvements de
troupe, il y a des il y a des axes de
pénétration différents." Bon bref, mais
rappelle-toi, tout le monde pensait que
c'était pratiquement improbable, que
c'était impossible, que finalement
c'était un trop gros morceau, que le
on a tous serré les fesses en gros.
C'est du déni,
pardon.
C'était du déni ?
Oui, bien sûr. Bien sûr que c'est du
déni. Bien sûr. Mais ça fait aussi
partie de la politique, si tu vois
certain moment
de dire "Non, non, vous inquiétez pas."
Par exemple, je te prends l'exemple,
toujours dans la crise actuelle,
Poutine joue la stratégie de la menace
et de l'angoisse. Il fait du discours,
je j'irai jusqu'au bout de mes
objectifs, d'ailleurs mais je mets en
alerte mes forces stratégiques et cetera
et cetera.
Toi, dirigeant occidental, qu'est-ce que
tu fais face à cette stratégie de la
menace ? Il est évidemment destiné à
faire peur à l'opinion publique
occidentale.
En jouant sur l'opinion publique, il
veut faire pression sur les dirigeants
occidentaux du genre tenez-vous à
carreau. Tu es d'accord ? C'est ça sa
logique. Je sais
pas bien sûr. Je pense qu'il a voulu
clairement mettre pression sur les
dirigeants.
Oui, mais en même temps son discours sur
le nucléaire par exemple n'a pas de
rationalité militaire.
Bon donc en en brandissant le nucléaire
si tu veux il fait il change le la
rubrique de communication
sur la la guerre.
Bon, rappelle-toi tout ce qui va
argumenter sur les dénazifier le régime
en Ukraine, enfin des trucs comme ça.
Mais ça, il fait référence à quelque
chose qui ne marche que dans l'opinion
publique russe. Personne en Occident
considère que Hitler bouge dans sa tombe
et qu'il va revenir. Mais tu vois bien
que pour les Russes si tu veux les il y
a une loi d'un énoncé un sociologue que
je trouve très rigolo. Je crois que ça
s'appelle la loi de Godwin qui dit quand
une polémique s'amplifie, la probabilité
qu'on utilise les termes fascisme,
stalinisme, terrorisme s'approche de un.
C'est tu vois c'est plus un débat, c'est
victive. Bon et donc on se dit euh le
il va parler de nucléaire.
Pourquoi ? On voit pas pourquoi. Euh
je te coupe un peu.
Ouais, vas-y.
2014-215, je rencontre des des reporters
de guerre russes.
Ouais,
d'accord.
Ouais.
On on discute
sur quel théâtre d'opération ?
Je rencontre des des reporters de guerre
russe.
Je discute avec eux. Le premier truc qui
m'ont montré, c'est des vidéos de de
l'Ukraine,
des cadavres. Euh, ils m'ont expliqué
qu'il y en a un qui a perdu 20 kg parce
que pendant 1 mois, il a dormi euh où il
rangeait les cadavres. Il me montre les
vidéos de ça, il me montre les frappes
qu' a qu' a.
C'est-à-dire du Donbas, les images du
Dombass. Ouais.
Et donc le premier truc qui montre,
c'est ça en disant "Ah, il y a la guerre
partout mais il y a une guerre que les
occidentaux ne veulent pas voir, c'est
ils sont en train de massacrer les
russes au fon."
Ouais.
Dès 2014-25.
Qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise ?
Bien sûr que ils y sont sortis. les
occidentaux, est-ce que les occidentaux
ont réellement perçu grâce à leurs
médias que ça cartonnait si fort là-bas
?
Il y a eu des reportages notamment fait
du côté du Donbas qu'on m'a cité
récemment où effectivement on montrait
20145 là. Non non mais justement je te
parle de ça parce que c'est un reportage
qui a 2 3 ans avant le début de la
guerre et effectivement il voit il
essayait de montrer la vue la vie vécu
par les Russes côté région sécessionist
Ukrainiens
pardon
c'était c'était toujours des Ukrainiens
à l'époque.
Mais attends tu es reporter de guerre il
montrait des cadavres russes ou des
cadavres
des cadavres ukrainiens ? Oui, mais
ukrainien à côté
du côté Donbas, il disait pas que
c'était des Russes. Non, bien sûr qu'il
disait pas que c'était des Russes, mais
enfin eux, ils se percevaient comme
Russes, sinon ils auraient pas fait
sécession. Bon et donc euh le euh
la marche vers la guerre suppose encore
une fois une préparation.
Rappelle-toi au début de la guerre
d'Algérie, ce qu'on appelait les
événements. On parlait pas de la guerre,
tu étais pas né mais enfin parler des On
commence par expliquer que l'effetaga
massacre. Et donc à partir de ce
moment-là, il faut envoyer l'armée parce
que il faut rétablir l'ordre pacifier.
Tu vois, c'était de la pacification.
Donc dans toutes les guerre, tu as cette
démarche expliquant que l'OT est le
méchant et que par nature, il respecte
pas les lois de la guerre.
Et donc est-ce que c'est
fondamentalement différent que les
Russes ai été sensibles à toutes ces
minorités dispersées à droite et à
gauche qui parfois était maltraité pense
que quand il y a la révolution de
Maidane, le nouveau régime commence par
imposer l'Ukrainien comme seule langue
officielle en Ukraine et il y a 30 % de
russophones en Ukraine. On aurait dû le
calmer le mec en disant "Écoutez,
arrêtez, c'est pas la peine de rejeter
de l'huile sur le feu." Mais
on on est-ce qu'on en avait les moyens ?
Est-ce que on aurait réussi à les
convaincre et cetera ? Toujours est-il
que le phénomène de génér de pour
susciter le conflit, il est pris aussi
par des par le régime nouveau. Bon, donc
c'est pour ça que je te dis que la
logique diplomatique ne l'a pas
suffisamment emporté dans toute cette
relation à la Russie parce que il
fallait à ce moment-là dire "Attendez,
attendez, ne n'adhérom pas tout de suite
à l'idée de la grande démocratie qui
progresse."
Il faut effectivement dans un pays où
encore une fois les frontières
staliniennes faisaient que toute façon
tu avais toujours ce genre de problème
avec des populations qui n'était pas qui
n'étaient pas homogène
doit être géré si possible avec un grand
conférence internationale sur le droit
des minorités, le respect des
frontières, tout ce que tu veux.
2è deè remarque,
la relation russoau-rainienne, si tu
veux est une relation complexe qui
s'inscrit dans le temps long.
Alors, c'est vrai qu'on te sort que Kief
était la capitale du de l'origine de la
de la Russie, la ville capitale qui
ensuite a migré et cetera vers Moscou.
Et donc c'est à ce titre-là que les
Russes vont se donner un espèce de droit
sur l'Ukraine. Bon,
ce processus là qui est le recours à
l'histoire pour prouver une légitimité
est un truc qu'on retrouve beaucoup dans
les conflits. Les Serbes disaient le
Kosovo, c'est là que né la Serbie, donc
on veut annexer le Kosovo. Bon, il y a
plus de Serbes sur place mais leur
argumentaire c'était ça. Les juifs
radicaux, c'est la terre qui nous a été
donnée par Dieu, ça s'étend jusqu'à le
frat.
Et les néoconservateurs, les
néovangéliques américains adhèrent à
cette vue. Si tu regardes sur des sites
néovangéliques américains, tu vois la
guerre, la géopolitique telle qu'il
imagine, c'est exactement la même que
celle des juifs radicaux. C'est-à-dire,
ils veulent redistribuer la carte du
Moyen-Orient, étape préalable à
l'arrivée du Messi. Donc, tu as des
motivations qui sont qui pèsent
notamment en démocratie par l'intérieur
que tu ne vois pas apparaître
automatiquement dans les télégrammes
diplomatiques mais qui sont des forces
qui vont pousser à la guerre. Alors, je
te coupe parce que tu parles de
télégramme diplomatique.
Il y a Wikileak, tu vois ce que c'est
Wikileaks qui a fait fuiter des
télégrammes diplomatiques, qui a fait
fuiter beaucoup de choses. Là récemment,
Wikileak republie euh des télégrammes où
il y a marqué clairement euh
télégramme de quoi ? Américain, russe
américain. Ouais.
Il marque clairement que l'approche de
l'OTAN aux frontières de la Russie,
c'est un cassus béli
générer des choses dramatiques.
Ouais,
ça les a pas arrêté, ils ont continué.
Oui, mais ce qui ce qui est intéressant
dans l'exemple que tu cites,
c'est le fait qu'encore une fois, il se
passe à l'intérieur des mécanismes de
pouvoir des prises de position parfois
très intelligentes et qui sont
véritablement proches de ce qui va se
passer. Mais la façon dont c'est pris,
la façon dont c'est entendu, c'est
complètement différent. Je te prends
volontairement des exemples autres.
Quand commencent les années sombres en
Algérie, au ministère de la défense, tu
as trois générations qui connaissent
tous l'Algérie. Tu as les militaires qui
ont fait la guerre d'Algérie. L'Algérie,
on connaît, on a fait la guerre. Tu as
les mecs qui ont été coopérants en
Algérie après 91 à l'époque où on
pensait le socialisme, l'industrie
industrialisante et puis travailler une
3è génération qui étaient des jeunes
universitaires qui connaissaient
l'Algérie d'après. Mais tu penses bien
qu'entre ces trois sociologies là, tu
avais des influences et des capacités de
décision qui étaient assez
fondamentalement différentes ? Donc
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne la
décision. Et et vis-à-vis de la Russie
par exemple, si tu veux, euh ce qui m'a
beaucoup frappé, c'est qu'encore une
fois sur les plateaux télés, tu as
beaucoup plus de bellicis que tu n'en as
dans les armées. Les armées savent ce
que c'est que la guerre. Donc euh avant
de s'engager là-dedans, il ils détestent
les opérations d'interposition, de
maintien de l'ordre et cetera parce que
si tu veux, ça les met dans une position
intenable. qui disent "Nous, on est là
pour faire la guerre, on n'est pas là
pour faire la gendarmerie, on n'est pas
là pour faire de l'interposition à
Sarayevo parce qu'à chaque fois par
exemple une fois à Sarayevo, j'y étais
regarder des moutons avec un flingue.
Ouais, mais beaucoup plus grave si tu
veux. Il y avait un
à Sarayevo, les casques bleus français
avaient constaté qu'il y avait un sniper
qui tirait d'une 15e ou 16e étage d'un
truc et cetera. Puis un beau jour, ils
en ont eu marre. Ils ont essayé de le
repérer, de monter. Bon et c'était une
vieille femme qui tirait parce que je
sais pas quoi son fils avait été tué
dans les truc mais c'était pas c'était
pas un bellant. Donc les militaires, ils
te disent mais nous on est là pour faire
la guerre. On n'est pas là encore une
fois pour faire de la police,
d'interposition ou de la du de
l'humanitaire et cetera. Et par contre
tu vois bien cette dérive qui commence
après 91. C'est-à-dire puisque de toute
façon nous avons des armées puisque
c'est elles servent à rien et donc et
puisque elles sont supérieures à tout,
on va en disperser absolument partout et
après le 11 septembre, on va faire des
guerres. Donc si tu veux quand on juge
Poutine aujourd'hui, j'espère que dans
l'antichambre de la Cour pénale
internationale où on veut le traîner, il
y aura George Bouche avant.
Pourquoi George Bouche ?
Ben George W Bouche parce que c'est lui
qui fait la guerre de c'est lui qui fait
la guerre d'Irak. Rappelle-toi cet
épisode extraordinaire 11 septembre donc
un traumatisme comme jamais l'Amérique
n'en avait connu. Pourquoi jamais ?
Parce que l'Amérique n'a jamais connu la
guerre sur son territoire. Le dernier
combattant de la guerre de sécession est
mort en 1955.
Bon, on peut pas dire que ça fasse un
rapport à la guerre, les villes
bombardées, les coupures d'eau,
l'étiquet de rationnant. Ils ne savent
pas ce que c'est. Le 11 septembre est un
choc évidemment gigantesque parce que
tout à coup en plein cœur de New York,
il y a effectivement les World Trade
Center et cetera et cetera. Or, le
premier discours que fait George Bush
sur l'état de l'Union en janvier 2002,
c'est de désigner l'axe du mal qui sont
l'Iran, l'Irak et la Corée du Nord.
Tu dis maintenant il y avait 19, il y
avait qu'un saoudien sur 19 terroristes.
Il décide de classifier secret des
Frances 28 pages du rapport du Congrès
qui concernaiit essentiellement les
rapports entre l'ambassade saoudienne et
les terroristes. C'était eux qui avaient
réservé les chambres d'hôtel et cetera.
Ces 28 pages ont été déclassifiées par
Obama 14 ans plus tard.
Donc tu vois dans la catégorie du
mensonge,
il faut reconnaître que si tu veux
Poutine a beaucoup à apprendre. Donc
quand tu rappelles ça, tu es pas
révisionniste, tu soutiens pas Poutine,
mais j'essaie de faire que de comprendre
pourquoi les guerres arrivent et parce
qu'en général pour se battre, il faut
être deux. Bon et donc c'est pas c'est
pas soutenir l'offensive de Poutine sur
l'Ukraine, c'est d'expliquer pourquoi on
en est arrivé là. Voilà. Et donc c'est
pas la peine d'en faire un malade
psychiatrique parce qu'encore une fois
si on devait se livrer à ça, tu sais
c'est le c'est le pouvoir hein qui est
en fout. Donc heureusement, il y a pas
Mais tu vois bien qu'entre le profil,
tu vois bien que nous par exemple
le seul homme qui aujourd'hui a eu une
analyse géopolitique crédible, le seul
président, c'était Chirak. Chirac, il
est le dernier gauliste.
Et de Vilpin.
Ah oui, avec de Vilpin évidemment et son
discours à la à l'ONU.
Tout de suite après, ces successeurs
Hollande et Sarkozy
vont vite faire pédaler pour reprendre
la route des Américains. Chirak avait
fait la guerre d'Algérie,
ça lui il savait ce que c'était que la
guerre, disons.
Hollande, c'est le président du conseil
général de la Corè, ce qui ne manque pas
de faire trembler Poutine. Et Sarkozi
était un espèce d'affolé si tu veux qui
croyait que tout le monde allait lui
céder. C'est lui qui va faire cette
catastrophe en Libye. Donc tu vois bien
qu'on a un problème de rapport des
dirigeants à la guerre non pas parce
qu'ils l'ont connu mais à la guerre par
rapport à la dimension de politique
intérieure. Qu'est-ce qu'on va passer de
moi si je fais ça ?
D'où les experts télévisels.
Donc nous effectivement à la fois
c'estes visiteurs du soir, c'est débats
sur les chaînes de télé et cetera. Par
exemple, il y avait un journaliste qui
me racontait là sur une sur un plateau
télé, il me disait "J'étais en Syrie, je
ne sais où à Hbil ou je sais pas quoi,
je reçois un coup de fil de Hollande,
racontez-moi alors comment ça se passe
et cetera." Tu t'attends ? Le président
de la République téléphone à un
journaliste pour lui demander comment
elle a truc en Syrie. Un mec qui était à
son cabinet à Hollande me racontait que
tous les matins, il ouvrait le journal,
il regardait ce qu'on disait de lui dans
le journal.
Tu veux que je reprenne doucement ou
c'est pas la peine ? Tu as compris ? Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? On a du mal à
imaginer que on a des dirigeants qui
n'ont plus d'expérience internationale.
Tu vois Macron il fait il fait ses
classes mais il est trop jeune pour
avoir une expérience. Hollande c'était
un élu local. Macron euh on on a beau le
le le critiquer sur plein de trucs là,
ce qu'il a essayé de faire avec les
Russes, il l'a senti.
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Mais ce qui est
indigne, c'est la façon dont on l'a
agressé en expliquant que il était
poutinien parce qu'il avait parlé avec
l'ennemi. Si tu parles pas avec ton
ennemi, je je vois pas avec qui tu peux
parler. Et donc si tu veux, ça prouve
l'indignité et la méconnaissance
internationale de la classe politique
que de se que faire de comment dire d'un
attitude comme celle-là qui est la
dernière tentative de négociation une
affaire de politique intérieure. C'est
ça qui est indigne. C'est pas le
comportement de Macron. Macron il essaie
de faire que alors après on va se moquer
sur la longueur de la table parce qu'il
était un bout l'autre bout et cetera.
Bon, je veux dire, puttin, sortons un
peu de ces de ces querelles
franco-françaises, si tu veux pour
on attend le le mouvement, si tu veux de
un peu de sursaut national pour qu'on
arrête de faire comme si moi j'aurais
fait beaucoup mieux si c'est
Qu'est-ce que tu entends par sursaut
national ?
Ben, on est quand même face à une
situation qui est quand même extrêmement
grave.
Il faut pas se tromper.
Il faut que le président reçoive les
principaux leaders de l'opposition, les
candidats et cetera pour leur expliquer
sa ligne pour que les mecs acceptent si
tu veux de adhèrent, critique, fasse
savoir le point de vue et cetera. Bon,
tu as vu cette polémique avec le fait
que il y a un mec de la France insumise
qui a expliqué que on livrait des
missiles Milan, des choses comme ça.
Bon,
était sorti d'ailleurs dans le monde
quelques jours avant. Oui, mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est la façon dont on
en fait une polémique. Euh,
on en fait une polémique parce que quand
même le mec est pr il est dans la
commission de défense.
Ou à la commission de défense. Ouais.
Mais en même temps,
journaliste sorte ça, on aura toujours
diplomatiquement l'opportunité de dire
que c'est un journaliste qui a raconté
de la merde.
Oui.
Facile.
Qu'un responsable politique qui fait
partie de la commission défense disent
ça, il fout la France dans la merde
parce que il y a la Russie qui a fait
une liste avec tous les petits pays
européens.
béliqueux envers la Russie. C'est un peu
comme les Anglais qui sont en train de
sermonner par médias interposés leurs
militaire qui ont déserté leur armée
pour les combattre en Ukraine.
Oui, d'accord. Maître
Non, non, je comprends. Mais si tu veux
le si tu veux le le cas, il a un double
un double aspect. Bon, le fait que la
France insoumise soit dans un espèce de
de pacifisme
névrotique, rappelle-toi que Mélenchant
avait proposé de désarmer la police
quand il y avait les gilets jaunes pour
un type qui veut devenir président de la
République. C'est intéressant comme
poussé. Et la deuxième chose, pardon,
je m'en rappelle pas.
Ah si si. Ouais. Il avait dit il faut
désarmer la police. Euh et deuxième
chose si tu veux le fait que on dévoile
quelque chose qui est vraiment qui est
d'un ridicule absolu. Qu'est-ce que tu
veux qu'on livre au types ? On va pas
leur livrer des avions de combat.
Même les avions de combat, il faut 6
mois pour former un pilote à condition
qu'il soit déjà pilote. Bon, donc on
sait très bien que c'est pas dans cette
gamme là que ça va jouer. Si tu veux
dire qu'on va livrer des missiles
antichar, qu'on va livrer des trucs et
cetera et cetera, bon ça fait c'est
plutôt un débat de politique intérieure,
c'est pas un débat. Les Russes se
doutent assez facilement de quelles sont
les armes qui seront les plus létales
pour eux.
Le problème, il va se poser dès que ces
armes seront utilisables,
ce qui est probablement euh en cours de
livraison et en cours de formation parce
que
les armées n'ont plus de stock.
J'étais avec un général dans un débat où
il m'expliquait que lui au Tchad quand
il avait justement de certains de ces
armes qu'on appelle des manpads,
c'estàdire des armes porté par le soldat
d'infanterie et qui ont des fortes
capacités destructrices, il m'a il me
disait "Mais moi, j'étais obligé de voir
et de vérifier les dates de péremption
sur chacun des missiles."
Et donc des fois, il disait "Non, je
peux pas, ça risque d'exploser par le
type qui utilise." Bon, donc il y a pas
de stock, il faut les acheter, faut les
reconstituer, faut les livrer, faut
former. Donc tu vois, on est déjà dans
un temps moyen, on n'est pas du jour au
lendemain. Bon que le type de la France
insoumise
en sorte qu'encore quelques-unes comme
ça, si tu veux, c'est pas c'est pas
possible. C'est pas grave.
Pardon ?
C'est pas grave.
Non, c'est pas grave. C'est pas grave.
Enfin, à mon avis, c'est pas grave. Je
veux dire, les Russes sont moins cons
que ça quoi. Et donc euh
revenons aux intellectuels médiatiques
bélicistes.
Il y a il y en a pas quelques-uns qui
relèvent le le niveau ?
Si si, il y en a il y en a plein. Mais
ce qui m'intéresse, si tu veux, c'est le
d'abord c'est la transformation qui
s'est passée, celle que j'ai essayé
d'expliquer, tu sais. C'est-à-dire que
on va avoir une espèce de multicouche.
Tu vas avoir le mec qui rentre dans le
théâtre de crise qui dit "Là-bas, il y a
un massacre qui est en train de se
préparer." Alors s'il y a pas minimum un
crime de guerre ou alors un génocide,
tu sors pas du lot. Il y a 400 crises à
la surface de la planète. Il faut que le
mec qui revient explique que c'est
vraiment dramatique.
C'est dramatique ce qui se passe en
Ukraine là quand même.
Ouais. Mais tu as vu les chiffres ? Tu
as vu les chiffres ? Pour le moment,
c'est une guerre qui qui tue peu.
Oui, par rapport à d'autres conflits.
Et ben oui,
mais et ben une vie c'est déjà trop.
Bah bien sûr que c'est vite, c'est trop.
Mais si tu veux, ils ont pas commencé
une campagne de bombardement sur les
villes. Ramenons les choses à leur juste
bombardement autre autre que le le tapis
de bombe façon irraakienne. C'est ça.
Oui, mais si tu veux, moi je lutte pas
je lutte contre la guerre. Pour lutter
contre la guerre, il faut dénoncer les
mauvais les mauvaises fois des deux
côtés. Que que Poutine soit
effectivement un type qui aujourd'hui
s'est convaincu que l'usage de la force
contre les occidentaux est le seul moyen
de faire falloir son point de vue, c'est
une évidence. Mais que tu es en face de
ça des gens qui ne se rendent pas compte
de ce qu'ils ont eux-mêmes fait et qui
se traduit au fait que quand on vote une
résolution à l'ONU, tu t'aperçois qu'il
y a des pays qui ne te soutiennent plus.
Je te prends l'exemple du Mali. Mali,
ils se sont abstenus. Le Mali est le
pays qui est le plus aidé par la France
et c'est celui qui a viré les soldats
français pour accueillir Wagner.
Tu vois bien qu'on est dans une
géopolitique qui est en train de changer
mais comme nos stratèges si tu veux
penser
Wagner pour les auditeurs qui
connaissent pas Wagner c'est des
mercenaires
soi-disant pas connectés avec le pouvoir
russe. Ce serait une entreprise privée
comme ça ?
Non, c'est ce qu'on appelle une société
militaire privée. Choses qui ont été
mercenaire. Attends, attends, attends,
attends. Prends-le le compte entre ça
s'appelle une société militaire privée,
concept qui a été inventé par l'Afrique
du Sud pour intervenir à la demande d'un
certain nombre d'États africains qui
ensuite s'est développé en Angleterre et
aux États-Unis. Wagner n'est que le
dernier petit dernier petits
le dernier né si tu veux de la
génération.
En Irak, à l'époque américaine, il y
avait plus de sociétés militaires
privées que de que de soldats de métier.
Bon, Blackwater
est une exemple de société militaire
privée américaine qui a commis des ex
qui maintenant Black Rock.
Oui, mais ça a changé vachement, tu
parles donc cette société était connue
pour avoir mis des exactions qui n'ont
jamais donné lieu à condamnation. Ils
ont réussi à les rattraper par le col
aux États-Unis parce qu'il y a quand
même aux États-Unis des ONG qui se
battent contre ça. Mais l'invention
n'est pas russe. Donc Wagner est pas
pire que Blackwater. Rappelle-toi qu'à
Abou Grahib, prison dans laquelle on a
enfermé des gens sans aucune motif
légal, sans aucune base juridique,
c'était des mecs de Black Water qui
faisaient les les interviews.
Tu vois leur respect que pas que pas
que. Non mais enfin tu vois le respect
des droits de l'homme que Black Water
est
la source de ça la source des des
interrogatoires par Black Cluter c'est
c'est quelle source ?
Pardon ?
C'est quelle source ?
Oh je sais plus, je peux plus te citer
ça si tu veux. Mais c'était pas des
soldats américains.
Bon euh si tu veux, on peut rester sur
quelque chose qui est pas mal aussi. Tu
te souviens de Guantanamour ? Le le
compte de vacances ?
Oui. Le compte de vacances,
tu sais combien il reste de mec à Ganamo
depuis 20 ans ? Il en reste 60.
Donc alors attends, tu dis [__] mais
arrêtons arrê qui n'est pas un camp de
vacances qui est une prison militaire où
ils ont des techniques de torture
dramatique où les gens se font ils
appellent ça waterbordés c'estàd
torturer avec de la flotte ils se font
torturer avec de la musique ils se font
torturer que pas plein de désolé pour
cet aparté
non mais l'histoire juridique si tu veux
d'augmenter un amot est assez
extraordinaire donc ils arrivent en Irak
ils ramassent des mecs à l'appel Il y a
des prisons aussi comme ça en Pologne,
c'est ça ? Non,
attends. Oui, il y a plusieurs choses si
tu veux. Il vont ramasser des mecs.
Les prisons et vol secrets de la CIA en
Europe.
Les prisons secrète de la CIA. Les
Guantanamo, c'est le plus symbolique.
Pourquoi est-ce que c'est Guantanamo ?
Parce que si tu veux hors du territoire
américain, ils ne sont pas justiciables
de la justice américaine qui auraient
été obligé d'investiguer, de demander
quelle était leur responsabilité et
cetera. Donc c'est un système totalement
une violation complète du droit
international et du droit américain.
Bon, il a été dénoncé, beaucoup de gens
sont mais si tu veux la prison n'est
toujours pas fermée parce qu'ils ne
savent pas quoi faire des mecs qui
restent.
Donc tu vois
dire il y a il y a opposants et
opposants russe le Poutine il va se
faire emprisonner Navalni, il va
l'empêcher de parler,
il va essayer de le buter quand même
avant.
Ah non c'est pas lui, c'est Scripal.
C'est Scripal.
Na lavalnie iltoxiqué quand même. Non
non je je sais pas peut-être je sais pas
ça me dit rien. Un café un café bizarre
à l'aéroport. Si si
c'est possible c'est possible. Mais si
tu veux voilà encore une fois euh
je te prends l'affaire Scripal. Scripal
donc tu sais c'est l'ancien mec du KGB
qui a vu
qui a trahi
alors oui qui a qui était passé à
l'ouest et qui a bu un café au polonium
je crois un truc dans ce genre-là. Bon
le mec
poigné de porte peut-être hein
une poignée de porte.
Ah non non. Enfin, moi j'avais vu queil
avait bu un truc dans lequel ils avaient
foutu du produit radioactif. Donc, le
mec a perdu ses cheveux et cetera. Il a
été rattrapé de justesse si tu veux
voir. Et c'était évident que c'était la
main des services de renseignement
russes. Bon,
Cachogi, il est découpé en morceaux dans
un consulat saoudia. Découpé en
morceaux. Le mec, il a trempé dans
l'acide. Et ensuite si les si les Turcs
n'avaient pas sonorisé tout le consulat,
on aurait pensé qu'il était
effectivement reparti.
Ou si on sonorisé tout le consulat ou un
petit Pegasus.
Pourquoi un petit Pegasus ? Non non, si
tu veux l'argumentaire des Saoudiens
c'était de dire non, il est reparti ou
enfin il est pas venu. Alors quand les
les Turcs ont montré les caméras de
surveillance extérieure pour dire voyez
il est arrivé. Ensuite il y est reparti.
Alors, ils ont montré qu'effectivement
dans les caméras au départ il y avait
plus Cachogi. Bon et donc tu te dis et
sa femme qui était là, qui était dehors
en train de l'attendre, si tu veux
témoigner qu'il est pas reparti et
cetera. Donc c'est les Turcs qui ont
révélé que la chose s'était passée dans
un lieu diplomatique saoudiaire, donc
avec une responsabilité évidente de des
autorités.
Alors après ce qui est rigolo si tu veux
c'est la façon dont joue le lobby
saoudien pour expliquer qu'en fait c'est
pas c'est pas sérieux, c'est pas ça
vient pas de c'était des des gens qui
ont qui ont dépassé leur mandat.
Alors, il y a un article qui est
absolument célèbre de
comment s'appelle ce chroniqueur que il
cite toujours les services de
renseignement la
le gros là
plus gros que toi.
Ouais. Ouais. Beaucoup plus gros que
moi. Oh [__] c'est pas possible
d'oublier son nom. C'est un c'est un
type qui a beaucoup qui a eu longtemps
des chroniques dans Libération, dans
France interre, France Culture et
cetera.
Euh et qui a une un argumentaire qui est
imparable parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il
veut prouver quelque chose, il cite les
services de renseignement.
Alors citer les services de
renseignement, c'est vachement bien
parce que d'abord ça donne le sentiment
que tu as des informations et ensuite tu
es sûr de n'être jamais critiqué. Il y a
jamais un service de renseignement qui
envoie un porte-parole pour dire
c'est et donc bon le nom va me revenir
mais il écrit un article extraordinaire
pour expliquer que d'après ses sources
de renseignement Cachogi a été tué par
les Turcs et pas par les Saoudiens.
C'est un scoop. Manque de bol. 3 jours
plus tard Mohamed Ben Salman reconnaît
que effectivement c'est lui qui a donné
l'ordre. Donc c'est une fake news.
C'est pas une fake news. C'est du lobby.
C'est du lobbing. C'est c'est une fake
news.
Mais oui, mais si tu veux, c'est une
fake news. Moi moi je m'en fous je m'en
fous de l'intituler. Ce qui m moi
çaappelle ça du mensonge. Mais bon,
c'est pas grave.
[__] comment est-ce qu'il s'appelle
ce type ? C'est pas possible.
Ça va te revenir. Ça va revenir.
Ça va revenir. Ouais. Donc
tu vois quand quand tu te fais épingler
comme ça, tu te dis mais la dignité
exige que tu disparaisses du champ
médiatique.
Les intellectuels médiatiques comme BHL,
comme celui que je viens de te citer,
comme d'autres sont ce qu'on appelle des
intellectuels tfales, c'est-à-dire
aucune critique n'accroche. Tu peux leur
dire "Hier vous avez raconté ça,
aujourd'hui vous dites le contraire."
Ils te disent "Hier j'avais raison,
aujourd'hui j'ai raison." Tu vois bien
avec BHL.
Donc pourquoi
? Pourquoi on les réinvite à chaque fois
? On les réinvite parce qu'ils font
partie, comme tu dis, d'un lobby.
On les rinvite parce qu'il y a que cela.
On les rinvite parce que c'est un tout
petit cercle parisien-parisaniste
où ils s'échangent à chaque fois les
mêmes pour aller faire leur petits
plateaux télé comme au cirque. Pourquoi
? Pourquoi ? Si tu veux, il y a toute
une bon d'abord en France, il y a une
espèce d'admiration pour les
intellectuels. C'est pas tôt que je vais
apprendre ça. Rappelle-toi cette
extraordinaire adoration qu'on avait
pour Sart. Donc individu intellectuel
qui s'est rarement aussi comment qui a
aligné les conneries en matière
internationale comme peu avant lui. Bon,
il a été Stalinien, il a été Maist, il a
été tout ce que tu veux. Alors qu'il y
avait en face un autre type qui
s'appelait Aaron et qui lui est resté
toujours la tête au-dessus des débats.
Bon et donc
Raymond Raymond Aaron.
Raymond Aaron. Oui, absolument. Et en
fait Sartre était une espèce d'idole.
C'était le type qui te disait alors
absolument tout ce qu'il fallait penser
d'eux. Alors il a été soutien de la de
la guerre d'indépendance en Algérie.
Donc après ça lui a fait sa notoriété
mais ensuite il a aligné toutes les
conneries qu'on pouvait imaginer.
Euh pour te donner un exemple,
pour te donner un exemple,
Sartre et Simon de Beauvoir
assistent à une
Claude Moniquet.
Non non, ça va me revenir, t'inquiète
pas. Je vais je
c'est quelqu'un qui qui nous le marque
sur le forum.
Non non, c'est enfin bref euh Claud
Moniqu il est pas gros. Non,
pardon.
Claude Moniqué, il est moins gros que
toi.
Qui ça ? Claude Moniqué.
Je sais pas qui c'est Claude Monique.
Non non mais quand je te dirai le nom,
ça va t'apparaître évident. Euh
euh
Sartre et Suon de Beauvoir assistent à
une représentation des massales
en compagnie de Autoabet le 6 juin 44 à
Paris. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? 6
juin 44, c'est le débarquement. Bon,
visiblement, les alliés n'avaient pas
besoin de lui.
Donc c'est un type qui a fait sa
carrière sous l'occupation. Alors après,
il va raconter qu'il était dans la
cellule de l'École normale supérieure et
cetera et cetera. Mais tu te dis euh
c'est quand même extraordinaire. Alors
que Camu qui était son grand ennemi euh
lui enfin ou son grand débatteur si tu
veux était traité de traître parce que
quand il était en Algérie, il essayait
de concilier les points de vues des
pieds noirs et des trucs et cetera.
C'est-à-dire, tu avais d'un côté un type
qui était un véritable imposteur comme
on a pour BHL si tu veux aujourd'hui,
mais qui occupait se rend d'intellectuel
labellisé, grand intellectuel du temps.
Ah, il faut pas dire imposteur, c'est
pas bien.
Ah non, c'est pas un imposteur, c'est un
menteur. C'est vrai, c'est pas pareil.
Tu feras les coupes que tu veux dans le
truc.
Non, mais ça on est en direct. Tu es au
courant ?
Bah écoute, qu'est-ce que tu veux que je
te dise ? un imposteur. Je te raconte un
épisode vécu. Je sais pas si je t'en ai
parlé mais est-ce que je t'ai parlé de
l'épisode avec le général Palomeros ?
Bon, c'est simple. J'étais dans un débat
il y a de tr jours à côté du général
Palomeros que je connais depuis
longtemps qui était chef d'état-major de
l'armée de l'air au moment de la guerre
en Libye. Bon et il me racontait comment
il a vu apparaître BHL dans son bureau
au moment où BHL voulait qu'on aille
bombarder la Libye et BHL lui expliquait
ce qu'était la Libye. Or il se trouve
que Palomeros comme pilote de chasse
avait combattu les Libyens au Tchad.
Tu vois la différence de pointure ? Il
me disait "Mais ce type raconte
n'importe quoi." Mais à partir où il
avait l'accès à l'Élysée,
il a reçu l'ordre d'aller intervenir. Il
est intervenu parce que c'est un
militaire. Mais c'est pour ça que si tu
veux, tu te dis comment arrêter la
mécanique
parce que c'est pas
Adler. Alexandre Adler, nom de Dieu,
c'est pas possible ça.
Ah c'est Adler le
c'est Adler le type qui écrit cet
article sur le fait que Kchogi c'est les
Turcs qui l'ont dépessé.
On l'entend plus beaucoup.
Il est malade je crois. Et voilà,
j'espère que sa santé va s'améliorer.
Alors, revenons revenons à nos affaires.
Euh
comment on fait pour éviter d'avoir des
intellectuels du très bellisticiste sur
les plateaux télé ? Il faut que ça
vienne de la population qui arrête de
les regarder.
Il faut que ça vient de la population
qui s
Écoute, je t'avoue que je t'avoue que je
suis moi-même posé la question parce que
ce sont des positions de pouvoir qui
s'acquièrent si tu veux.
Euh par exemple, BHL a toutes les
semaines une chronique en dernière page
du point. Donc je l'ai demandé à des à
des copains du point. J'ai dit écoute ce
type ils me disent oui mais il a
l'oreille du patron donc il garde sa
dernière page.
B l'autre il avait Adler il avait ses
chroniques sur France Culture épisode
vécu avec Adler
on crée la délégation aux affaires
stratégiques en 92 et on le trouve dans
les meubles parce qu'il avait été
recruté par la structure précédente. Bon
on fait une séance de travail sur la
Turquie.
Je sais plus quelles étaient les
circonstances mais enfin peu importe.
Donc Adler prend la parole et Adler
c'est un compteur. C'est un qui prend la
parole, tu l'écoutes, c'est fascinant.
Tu as l'impression que tu as le monde
qui se déroule devant toi. Et il cite
des instructions du KGB l'un de je sais
pas du 12 mars 1954 et une autre
instruction du du 5 janvier.
Je me tourne vers le type de la DGSE, je
dis mais c'est intéressant son truc là,
vous les avez ces instructions ? Le type
me dit "Non, il ment, il invente."
Tu te rends compte de ce type, il le
disait froidement. C'est-à-dire qu'il n'
accordé aucun crédit à ce que racontait
ce type qui était censé être un grand
intellectuel français spécialiste des
questions stratégiques.
Changeons le sujet parce qu'il est mal,
il pourra pas revenir.
Euh,
revenons au 21e siècle.
Oui.
Où il y a de l'infantinement.
Hm
hm. où Cyril Anouna a plus de popularité
que beaucoup d'émissions
géopolitiques ou très arides ou très
compliquées.
Ouais.
Où on se retrouve avec France 24 qui
fait
pas de l'info mode mais qui qui pas trop
trop équilibré
qui invite aussi ses intellectuels
médiatiques.
Comment on fait pour se réapproprier la
chose ? Comment la population ? Il faut
qu'il y ait un mouvement anti-guerre
très fort civil.
Non, d'abord la première ch comprennent
que
bah ça marche plus et qu'en plus être
belliciste ça nous emmène au carton.
Comment on fait Pierre ?
Bah d'abord je te je salue Syerview.
Bah oui mais enfin je veux dire il faut
quand même te rendre compte que si tu
veux vous connaissez vous connaissez
vous ne mesurez peut-être pas
l'influence que vous avez. Moi, il y a
des gens qui m'arrêtent dans la rue en
disant "On vous a vu sur Syerview". Ils
m'ont pas dit "On vous a vu sur BFM ou
sur C News". Parce que la transformation
fondamentale qu'on introduit ces chaînes
d'info en continu, c'est que si tu veux
à partir du moment où il y a un
événement, euh il faut tout de suite
réunir un plateau, discuter et cetera
avant qu'on sache quel est le sens de
l'événement. Comme si on avait tout de
suite des gens qui allaient te dire
"Non, non, mais vous allez voir, il va
faire ça après, et cetera et cetera."
Et donc il y a une espèce, tu sais une
chaîne d'info en continue. Ça ça fait à
peu près 8 à 10 minutes d'information
réelle et puis ensuite tu as des pages
de pub et puis ensuite tu as des débats.
Donc il faut peupler ces plateaux. Et tu
vois bien que depuis le début de la
guerre au en Ukraine, tu as vu le nombre
de gens qui se sont succédés et donc tu
as tout à coup un espèce de débat
continu qui va s'installer partout qui
et ce débat il a un avantage, c'est
qu'il interpelle le politique
directement. Donc si tu as un attentat
par exemple phénomène sécuritaire grave,
tu vas tout de suite avoir des gens qui
vont accéder au plateau en disant "Oui
mais l'attentat c'est si c'est ça que
fait le gouvernement ?" Tu vois ce que
je veux dire ? Il y a un cour ça court
circuite y compris le parlement
c'est-à-dire de dire d'un seul coup mais
c'est pas possible comment est-ce qu'on
assure la sécurité des Français ?
Comment est-ce possible ? Pourquoi
est-ce que ça a failli ? Enfin, tu vois,
et parce que encore une fois ce euh ces
chaînes d'info en continue, moi des fois
on m'appelle en me disant il y a eu un
tel truc, un tel endroit, euh est-ce que
vous pouvez qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire ? Mais je sais pas si un
mec qui a tiré sur sa femme ou si c'est
un type qui s'est blessé au pied en
nettoyant son arbre. Parce que
l'urgence, l'immédiateté si tu en vis
dans le dans le présentisme si tu veux,
c'est on va vous dire tout de suite ce
que ce qu'ils font en penser. Bon et ben
automatiquement ça se peuple de gens
qu'on va aller racler les fonds de
tiroir, on va aller chercher des des
anciens des militaires, des des des
intellectuels médiatiques, des
spécialistes et cetera et cetera.
Adler a quand même le mérite d'avoir
traduit le rapport de la CIA.
Non, il l'a introduit. Non non, c'est
pas du tout pareil. Non non, il a on lui
a demandé de faire la préface.
Très bien. Très bien. Moi, j'ai rien à
dire sur le fait qu'il fasse les
préfaces. Je ne fais que citer des
exemples dans lesquels il s'est planté
d'une manière et hontée et qu'à partir
de ce moment-là, la moindre des choses
aurait été de se dire je me mets en
retrait. Bon, finalement, il s'est mis
en retrait. Mais
chose dans l'économie d'ailleurs, hein.
A il y a le même problème dans
l'économie.
Est-ce qu'on peut avoir ton avis sur les
sanctions, la politique de sanction ?
Est-ce que ça marche ? Ça marche pas ?
Est-ce que ça fait ses preuves ? Est-ce
que en fait on n'est pas en train de se
tirer une balle dans le pied ? Est-ce
que il y avait pas d'autres moyens ?
Écoute, bon d'abord je te ferai
remarquer qu'effectivement on n' jamais
pris de sanction contre les États-Unis
après l'invasion de l'Irak. Tu vas me
dire que c'est peut-être une obsession,
mais enfin il vaut mieux le rappeler.
Bon là on est on a
pris des sanctions parce qu'ils se sont
assis sur le droit international.
Pardon.
Comment ?
Pardon, j'ai pas compris ta question.
Parce que ils se sont assis sur le le
droit international.
Bah bien sûr. Ouais.
Puis qui voulait prendre des sanctions
contre les États-Unis ?
Parce qu'ils ont tiré de l'uranium
impouvri un peu partout.
Bah ça si tu veux ça fait partie des
crimes de guerre mais là on parle
embargo. Il y a pas eu d'embargo contre
les États-Unis au moment de la guerre en
Irak. Au contraire, le seul embargo,
c'est Chirac disant on veut pas y aller.
Bon, on peut pas considérer que c'est un
embargo. Donc là, on est dans quelque
chose si tu veux qui est complètement
nouveau, qui est tout à fait cette
reconstitution de l'ennemi dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure. C'est dire
celui-là, c'est le méchant,
donc il faut le sanctionner.
Donc celui-là, il faut le sanctionner.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on a comme moyen si
on veut pas la guerre ? C'est
effectivement la politique des
sanctions. Je rappelle qu'il y a
quelques épisodes dramatiques qu'il faut
que les auditeurs sachent. L'embargo le
plus terrible qu'on a implant qu'on a
utilisé, c'est celui contre Saddam
Hussein qui a duré de 92 jusqu'à
pratiquement 2002. Pendant 10 ans,
l'Irak a été privé de tout. On avait
inventé un truc qui s'appelait pétrole
contre nourriture, c'est-à-dire que les
les organismes occidentaux vérifaient
l'exportation de pétrole en garantissant
qu'on ça permettrait d'acheter de la
nourriture. Tu vois le l'ignominie du
système interdiction de toute nature. Je
t'ai expliqué les produits
pharmaceutiques, les produits
d'entretien et cetera et cetera. Bon,
c'est une honte. C'est une honte contre
lesquelles beaucoup d'ONG se sont levés
en disant mais enfin la population
irakienne n'a pas de responsabilité dans
le comportement de Saddam Hussein. Donc
on toucher là un problème que qu'on
connaît tous, c'est que les sanctions ça
pénalise la population d'abord.
Alors moi je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable. C'est eux qui ont voté pour
Poutine.
Pardon ?
C'est eux qui ont voté pour Poutine.
Bah si tu veux. Donc si c'est eux qui
ont voté, c'est eux qui doivent assumer.
Ah bah oui, bien sûr. Mais enfin, il
reste que si tu veux, si ça tombe dans
les maternités, qu'il y a plus de les il
y a plus le lait pour les enfants et
cetera, tu descends un peu bas droit de
vote. Non, qui est des sanctions, c'est
une chose, mais tu vois bien que les
sanctions, si elles sont appliquées en
détectant les avoirs des oligarques,
c'est quand même beaucoup plus judicieux
et beaucoup plus efficace que si tu fais
des sanctions internationales qui vont
toucher toute la population.
Alors, il y a un grand mouvement de de
solidarité donc dans les sanctions. Moi,
les seules questions que je me pose, je
me dis "Mais est-ce que la City va
vraiment jouer le jeu ?" J'ai quelques
doutes, hein.
Ils ont ils ont sorti les banques euh de
Swift.
Ah non, mais Swift, c'est un organisme
international. C'est pas les sanctions
sur la City. C'est pas les sanctions sur
la City. Deuxième chose, est-ce que le
Crédit Suisse va appliquer ? Tu sais le
crédit suisse les swisse papers,
c'est-à-dire on a montré combien ce
cette banque avait servi de de refuge de
Havre à tous les l'argent sale de la
planète. Est-ce qu'ils vont appliquer ?
Ils vont pas se ruiner quand même. Les
banquiers vont pas se tirer une balle
dans le pied. Donc tu vois ce que je
veux dire entre le déclaratoire et le
réel. J'attends de savoir qu'est-ce que
va être le réel.
Donc les sanctions ça marche pas. Ça ne
fait que
non non, ça marche, ça marche. Mais ce
que j'aime bien aussi dénoncer, c'est
l'espèce de dignité dans lequelle se
drape si tu veux tous ces gens qui
disent faire des sanctions très dures et
cetera. Quand tu connais combien les
types ont été hypocrites avec l'argent
sale pendant des années, donc est-ce
qu'ils vont aller jusqu'à Alors, si
effectivement ils accaparent les avoir,
c'est bien là, au moins ça leur coûte
pas de fric mais tu vois bien que c'est
ces gens-là, c'est le crédit suisse sur
lequel sont sortis tous les papiers
qu'on fait les consortiums de
journalistes qui montrent que cette
banque était totalement vérolée.
Alors rappelle-toi, je sais pas si est
sorti de sa neutralité sur les
sanctions. Oui, mais je sais pas si tu
te souviens d'un type qui s'appelait
Jean Zigler qui il y a une quarantaine
d'années avait écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelait une Suisse au-dessus de tout
soupçon. Jean Zigler, je crois qu'on l'a
reçu deux fois ici.
Je sais pas parce que le type doit être
très très vieux. Mais enfin si tu veux,
ce type, il était un député Sus qui se
scandalisait du fait que le secret
bancaire soit opposable à toute
investigation internationale.
C'est quelqu'un d'absolument adorable
d'ailleurs.
Ah ben tant mieux si vous l'avez
retrouvé. En tout cas, saluez de ma part
parce que je trouve c'est un type qui a
fait un boulot formidable. Mais il y a
20 ans, il était considéré comme un
salot par les Suisses parce qu'il
s'attaquaient à quelque chose qui était
la condition même de leur prospérité,
c'est-à-dire le secret bancaire. Là, les
Suisses disent qu'ils vont participer,
tant mieux, mais ils ont du boulot,
hein. Le
le fait qu'on interdise
les chats russes dans les expositions,
les quoi ? Les
les chats russes,
c'est les agents du KGB. Non,
non, je sais pas.
Le fait
ça va très loin si tu veux mais c'est
vrai que
fait que McDonald's s'en aille de
Russie.
Oui. Bon les
le fait qu'on boycotte la vodka.
Est-ce que ça ressemble à quand Shirak
voulait plus voulait pas aller faire la
guerre et que les Américains ont ont
renommé les frites ?
Ouais. Ouais. Les French fries. Ouais.
Les French fries se sont ont été
renommés avec les Liberty France. Ouais.
Non, mais tu sais dans ces périodes de
paroxisme, d'opinion publique, tu as
toujours il y a une compétition dans la
connerie quand même. Qui peut en qui
inventé le le plus le plus
extraordinaire ? Moi ce qui me frappe
par exemple aujourd'hui
c'était peut-être important je te
tu parles des frites.
Non, c'est toujours important les
frites. C'était peut-être important de
marquer le coup
en en en isolant totalement le la Russie
à la
Non non mais bien entendu que les
sanctions sont extrêmement importantes
mais encore une fois moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est comment est-ce qu'on
crée une illusion de la guerre. Donc
effectivement les sanctions extrêmement
important et pour la première fois on a
effectivement un consortium occidental
quasiment uniquement du truc. Mais je te
prends un exemple très bête qui parle du
Linstein.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? On va
tomber sur le Lsteinstein est un état
mafia en plaçante de l'Europe. C'est un
état dans lequel tous les contribuables
allemands se sont réfugiés quand ils
voulaient frauder le fisque allemand.
Bon, je sais pas ce qu'il y a dans les
banques du Linstein, mais ce qui est
certain que leur ligne de conduite c'est
dire nous on ne parle de rien, on ne
connaît pas, on nous on s'ignore et
cetera et cetera. Tu vois quand il y
avait les anglais à l'intérieur de
l'Union européenne, je crois qu'il y
avait 35 paradis fiscaux à l'intérieur
de l'espace de l'Union européenne. 35
parce que tu avais Linstein, tu avais le
Luxembourg, tu avais des trucs comme ça
et cetera. C'est ceux-là qui vont
appliquer les sanctions dures à l'égard
de la Russie. On a même pas balayé chez
nous. On a même pas balayé chez nous. Et
tout à coup, on va dire attention un
exemple
pas mal. Boris Johnson annonce queil va
ouvrir un guichet spécial à Calé pour
les Ukrainiens réfugiés.
C'est horrible.
Ça veut dire il nous laisse les Arabes
et il prend les Ukrainiens.
Non, ça c'est ça c'était vraiment
horrible.
Bah c'est un c'est un raciste. Pourquoi
on le dit pas ? Pourquoi on le dit pas ?
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Le les
médias informment la distance critique
c'est aussi leur boulot mais ça n'est
pas que leur boulot. Donc, il y a des
moments où il faut effectivement dire,
excusez-moi, je m'étonne que monsieur
Bon Boris Johnson préfère nous laisser
tous les réfugie afghans, pakistanais,
syriens et cetera et cetera qui viennent
d'une guerre auquelle il a contribué en
tant que puissance britannique. Voilà.
Bon, mais je suis un individu chagrin.
Donc, revenons aux sanctions. Est-ce que
ça va pas nous emmener encore plus dans
une situation délétaire ? Bien sûr, bien
sûr.
Quand Bruno le maire dit
"On va genou l'économie russe".
Non, il dit "On est entré dans une
guerre économique." Il a dit
"Ger économique."
Bah si tu veux,
mets-toi dans la position d'un décideur
occidental qui sait que les sanctions
vont sont un espèce d'effet boomerang.
On va sanctionner les Russes mais
évidemment les Russes vont nous
sanctionner aussi.
Quel discours tu tiens à ta population ?
Est-ce que tu fais le le bras de fer en
disant ouais mais vous allez voir, vous
allez voir. Bon, la France est un pays
qui est structurellement déficitaire en
matière de commerce extérieur si tu
veux. Bon, la Russie n'est pas un un
partenaire très important. Je crois que
c'est 2 à 3 % du commerce extérieur
français. Mais enfin, c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est un état. C'est pas
l'Allemagne, il y a pas des réserves de
change gigantesque et cetera. Bon,
qu'est-ce que tu fais ? Est-ce que tu
tiens le discours
de la réplique ? Tu sais Poutine joue le
discours de la menace et de créer
susciter de l'angoisse dans la
population l'opinion publique puisque il
hésite pas à dire j'ai demandé à mes
forces stratégiques de se tenir en
éveil. Bon est-ce que toi dirigeant
occidental tu'en rajoutes ou au
contraire tu calmes ? Tu vois bien que
le maire probablement sa langue a
fourché, mais il a plutôt un discours à
rassurer pour dire toute façon s'il y a
de la pénuie, nous organisons pour que
cette pignerie pèse de manière équitable
sur toutes les populations. Tu vois ce
que je veux dire ? Son discours ça
devrait être celui-là. Nous allons
mobiliser les préfets, les collectivités
locales pour que dans des endroits dans
lesquels il y a des graves pénuies, on
puisse gérer si tu veux euh les choses.
Ça c'est un discours de la du sérieux,
de la rationalité parce que ça donne
l'impression que tu penses tout ton
système, non pas par rapport aux Russes
mais par rapport aux populations
françaises.
Il va pas pouvoir le faire. Quoi qu'il
arrive, il
quoi qu'il arrive, ils pourront pas le
faire. Faut pas faire quoi ? Tu veux
dire ?
Gérer les pénuries.
Mais en tout cas, il faut mieux le dire.
Est-ce que il faut dire qu'on peut pas
gérer les pénuries ? Non, il y a pas de
raison de dire que tu ne peux pas gérer
les pénuries. Pourquoi tu le dirais ? Si
tu dis que même si on a des difficultés,
qu'on commence tout de suite à se bouger
les fesses pour trouver des contrats
avec l'Australie, avec le Canada, avec
la truc, qu'on essaie de trouver tout de
suite des choses qui vont manquer, dont
on sait qu'ils vont manquer, tu le vois
bien avec le avec l'énergie. Bon, dire,
montrer, donner le sentiment qu'on se
mobilise et qu'on va essayer de faire
face à la péniorie qui de toute façon
sera évidente, ça me paraît un discours
de responsabilité politique. Maintenant,
il y a des domaines dans lesquels tu
sais très bien que ça va poser problème.
Si tu sais que on compte sur les
Américains par exemple pour compenser
une partie du déficit énergétique de
l'Europe, tu sais qu'en fait il risque
de nous vendre du gaz ou du pétrole de
chiste.
Liquié.
Liquéfier. Non, enfin bon, tu vois le
débat que ça va créer.
C'est bon pour l'écologie, non ?
Pardon ? Et oui, mais justement, tu vois
le débat, c'est-à-dire quelle va être la
posture des écologistes si on dit "Oui,
mais on va importer du gaz et du pétrole
de chisse des États-Unis
et puis ensuite relancer le nucléaire."
Et relancer le nucléaire, tu vois le
débat aussi. Donc tu vois bien que la
position d'un gouvernant, c'est quand
même une espèce d'exercice d'équilibre
où il faut montrer qu'on se préoccupe,
qu'on agit et qu'on fait de qu'on fait
quelque chose qui va peut-être vexer,
qui va peut-être fâcher, qui va
peut-être créer des débats intérieurs,
mais faute de trouver la baguette
magique qui va résoudre tout.
Revenons revenons aux intellectuels euh
médiatiques.
C'est quoi l'expression ? C'est le lobby
militarointellectuel.
Le lobby militarointellectuel.
Ouais. Pourquoi avoir faire des
recherches là-dessus ? Parce que si tu
veux dans toute l'époque de la guerre
froide, on a fonctionné sur l'analyse
qu'avait fait Eisenhower en 1953
où il disait qu'il fallait se méfier de
l'industrie de défense qui dans le
contexte de la guerre froide avait pris
un une dimension gigantesque et dont il
craignait que ça influence les décisions
politiques. Donc il avait inventé le
l'idée de complexe militaro-industriel
et tu vois bien que dans Tintin et
l'oreille cassée,
le trafiquant d'armes, c'est le mec qui
se balade avec ses petites valises, tu
sais, et qui va provoquer la guerre.
Bon, donc on est sur quelque chose, si
tu veux, qui est une image qui
effectivement a d'autant plus pris eu de
prise pendant l'époque de la guerre
froide, qu'on était dans une course aux
armements, c'est-à-dire que il fallait
toujours avoir lancé le programme qui
allait dépasser l'autre dans sa course
aux armements et cetera. Tu sais ce qui
est en train de se passer en ce moment
là ? Le le réarmement des pays
occidentaux est en train de se faire
vitesse grand V.
Ouais. Enfin, quand tu vois l'état de
décrépitude de l'armée allemande, tu te
dis il y a du boulot, hein. Je veux
dire, ils on ils peuvent annoncer je
sais pas combien de milliards de
dépenses. Mais avant de reformer, tu
sais que les caisses qu'ils ont envoyé
de missil's ont envoyé en en Ukraine,
elles étaient pourris. Les missiles
étaient de la date de péremption passée.
Donc ils ont pris dans leur stock mais
des stocks qui étaient même plus gérés
avec le minimum de de sérieux. Donc
avant que le les occidentaux se
réarment, refassent des armées et
cetera, on bute sur quelque chose qui
est quelque chose de très important qui
est une transformation qui s'est passé
dans les années 90-95,
c'est qu'on a supprimé le service
militaire. Bon et donc on a considéré
que la guerre de l'avenir c'était la
guerre de haute technologie donc servie
par des militaires de guerrière avec des
spécialistes et cetera et cetera. Quoi ?
C'est c'est effectivement des des
l'armée de métier qu'on a envoyé puisque
euh après la guerre du golf si tu veux
le parlement a dit que doréen avant on
pouvait plus envoyer des appelés sauf
s'ils étaient d'accord. Donc la
discussion a commencé finalement on
s'est dit bah ils vont mieux basculer
dans l'armée de métier ce qui évidemment
réduit le format puisque les mecs
doivent être payés quand même. Mais
évidemment il faut compenser avec de la
haute technologie mais simplement une
armée de métier c'est une armée de choc
frontal violent.
C'est pas une armée d'occupation, c'est
pas une armée d'interposition. Donc tu
vois que le format, il était celui du
scénario le plus grave, le scénario
suprême.
Dans l'armée russe, c'est un peu autre
chose. Ils ont gardé les appelés en
partie. En partie parce que justement
l'armée était tellement en fait
nécessiteuse, la crise avait été telle
que le seul réservoir gratuit si tu
veux, c'est les appelés. Donc ils ont
gardé cette proportion de d'appeler
qu'on va retrouver en Ukraine. Et cela
c'est un élément de fragilité important
de l'armée russe parce que ceux qui vont
être tués si tu veux là-bas, on raconte,
je sais pas si c'est vrai, on raconte
que euh ils ont emporté des crématoires,
des crématoriums mobiles.
C'est quoi ta source ?
Je sais pas, je l'ai lu dans un journal,
j'ai pas de source. Mais si tu veux, je
me dis la question je la comprends.
Est-ce qu'on rapatrie le corps des
appelés ?
Tu vois ce que comment qu'est-ce que ça
suscite dans l'opinion là-baska qui voit
son fils rentrer dans un cercueil ou
démembrer et cetera et cetera. C'est un
relais d'opinion publique interne.
C'est pour ça que les Ukrainiens font
parler les prisonniers de guerre
directement à leur maman. C'est ça.
Peut-être. Peut-être. C'est pas
impossible. Oui, bien sûr. Bien sûr.
C'est en tout cas c'est de bonne guerre.
Ouais, mais je sais pas, tu sais, on
trouve tellement d'informations, moi
j'essaie plutôt de penser l'intérêt
stratégique de chacune des informations.
Bon, quand j'entends un mec m'expliquer
que les Russes sont décidés à utiliser
du nucléaire sur l'Ukraine pour montrer
leur détermination,
j'ai un peu tendance à penser que c'est
pas très c'est pas très sérieux. Voilà.
C'était un papier de libération. Guerre
en Ukraine des crématoriums mobiles
sont-ils déployés par l'armée russe pour
brûler des corps des le corps des
soldats ?
Oui. Oui, c'est ça. C'était en
libération. Et le qui est-ce qui a écrit
ça ?
utiliser des vidéos de date de 2013
papier du 24 février 2022 de Carla
Monaco et de Anaïs Condomine.
Bon, c'est très récent. Cela dit, tu
vois pas pourquoi il ferait brûler les
corps alors qu'ils peuvent les enterrer
sur place hein, je veux dire. Mais
enfin, tu vois, ça fait partie de cette
guerre de l'information. C'est-à-dire
plus on suppose que l'autre va déployer
une perphidie, une espèce d'ignominie et
cetera, plus tu le
pas c'est pas prouvé hein.
Non non, justement c'est pour ça que je
le dis, c'est que si tu veux, tu vois
pas pourquoi les mecs feraient brûler
les les corps alors qu'ils peuvent les
enterrer sur place. Bon et donc ça
participe de cette guerre de
l'information où tu vas dire vraiment
l'autre c'est le mal absolu, c'est un
mec ignomigneux, ils sont prêts à faire
brûler les cadavres et cetera.
J'y crois pas. Je sais pas, ça peut être
vrai, ça peut être faux, mais peu
importe. Est-ce que tu suis la campagne
présidentielle ?
Un petit peu. Oui, comme tous les
euh qui est est le plus apte à à gérer
la situation internationale ?
Bah écoute, moi ce qui me frappe
beaucoup, c'est que Macron a été l'objet
de toutes les critiques. C'estàd toute
l'opposition s'est mobilisée pour le
critiquer. Il suffisait qu'il dise oui
pour que tous les autres disent non. Il
suffisait de disent non pour que tous
les autres disent oui. Bon, or, tu
t'aperçois que dans les sondages, c'est
le seul qui surnage. Ça veut dire que
l'opinion publique, si tu veux,
n'accorde plus aucun crédit à la classe
politique.
Et cette classe politique, elle s'est
traduit par le fait que tout à coup,
c'est un outsider qui a été élu. C'est
quand même lui qui qui succède
à Hollande et d'autre part le fait que
si tu veux, tu as des tas de nouveaux
dans cette et notamment Zemour. qui est
un nouveau venu venu du monde du journal
pour arriver à si tu veux compétiter
avec des vieux briscards de la
République. Donc c'est le phénomène est
extrêmement intéressant parce que ça
prouve que la classe politique a besoin
de se régénérer.
Cette classe politique, rappelle-toi,
elle est pour l'essentiel composée de
gens comme moi, c'est-à-dire de gens qui
ont fait les grandes écoles qui ont fait
J'avais un patron par exemple, c'était
très intéressant.
Ce coup, les crématorium mobiles ont été
débunqués par il y a de tr jours d'après
ont été quoi ?
Débqué, ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire que c'est une connerie.
Non, mais c'est intéressant comme fake
news. C'estàd plus tu charges le
l'ignominie des Russes, plus ça a des
chances de prendre.
Revenons à la classe politique.
Oui, la classe politique si tu veux.
Il y a une matrice qui est très forte en
France que tu connais, c'est celle des
grands corps de l'État qui sont les Nat,
la cor des mines et cetera et cetera.
Et qu'est-ce qui caractérise ces gens ?
que en général
ils ont un cycle qui après le bac se
fait sous forme classe prépa normal sup
science ena ou ou x cord desmine et
cetera ensuite cabinet et donc pendant
10 ans, ils ont pas posé les pieds par
terre
puisqu'ils ont fait que des études et on
les met tout à coup des postes de
responsabilité. Tu vois ce que je veux
dire ? Bon donc
qu'est-ce que tu vas comment dire quand
il y a une élite qui est aussi homogène
que celle-là ? On essaie effectivement
d'ouvrir mais les partis politiques sont
quand même très jaloux si tu veux que si
tu milie dans un parti politique tu dis
telle circonscription je la veux regarde
c'est goen royal elle voulait absolument
qu'on lui réserve une circonscription
les électeurs s'en foutaient donc tu
vois le cette espèce de comment dire de
d'homogénéité sociologique de la classe
dirigeante se traduit aujourd'hui par le
fait que tu en as aucun qui cette
comment dire cette
ce
Oui,
ce profil excepté Macron qui lui est un
pur produit hein quand même. C'est un
pur produit inspection des finances,
banque d'affaires et cetera. Tu te dis
au moins celui-là il a fait ses preuves.
Et que finalement les Français sont
convaincus que la par exemple sa gestion
de la crise a pas été aussi
catastrophique que la que le disait
l'opposition. Donc au lieu que
l'opposition se mette dans une position
intelligente vis-à-vis de ce type qui
était celui qui s'en sortait le mieux,
ils se sont cantonnés si tu veux à
critiquer tout ce qu'il pouvait faire.
Même s'il disait qu'il faisait beau, les
autres disaient qu'il faisait mauvais.
plus rien en tirer.
Ben ces petitci suppose que a un énorme
renouvellement de la classe politique.
Mais tu sais les les hommes politiques
c'est comme les arapes sur les rochers
hein. Je veux dire avant de les déloger
comme les morpions. Non,
je n'irai pas jusqu'à cette comparaison
cher ami. Mais tu vois le tu vois le
truc c'est-à-dire que c'est vrai en même
temps qu'une légitimité politique se se
construit sur une emprise locale. Donc
si le type veut être élu, il y a le
phénomène des parachutages. Mais le
phénomène des parachutages, ça veut dire
qu'on te prend un des mecs issu de cette
catégorie pour lui dire non mais tu vas
te mettre à Montellivar est. Tu vois ce
que je veux dire ? C'est Golen Royal,
ils l'ont baladé comme ça parce qu'ils
arrivaient pas à lui trouver une une
circonscription.
Une ville magnifique
est une très belle ville surtout la
partie est que je ne connais pas.
On va prendre deux trois questions
internet
à la volée.
Beaucoup de questions sur les sanctions.
Ouais,
je vais on on va juste les les
synthétiser. Le fait que les Russes se
soient préparés depuis des années à
recevoir des sanctions occidentales, le
fait qu'ils aient accumulé de l'or,
qu'ils aient baissé leurs dettes, qu'il
soient préparé leur quoi ? Pardon ? leur
dette.
Hm hm.
Le fait qu'il se soit euh fourni en
armement, le fait qu'il se soit préparé
à sortir de de de l'internet, le fait
qu'il se soit préparé à tout un tas de
sanctions
depuis des années.
Ces sanctions, ça va pas faire
grand-chose. Ça va les énerver encore
plus ou pas ? Ça va les mettre à genou
ou pas ? Est-ce que ça va les rendre
beaucoup plus béliqueux ou pas ? Est-ce
que il y avait pas autre chose à faire
que ça ? Écoute, bon euh sur le cas des
sanctions, moi je t'avoue que je connais
pas suffisamment la Russie pour
connaître les forces et les faiblesses
de la Russie. Bon euh ce qui est
certain, c'est que tu vois bien qu'il y
a des banques d'affaires russes qui sont
directement menacées par les sanctions,
que le rouble lui-même a fléchit et donc
que euh et puis il reste l'opinion
publique, c'est-à-dire la population qui
est une population qui est habituée aux
pénuries pour le cas de la Russie, hein,
même si le développement économique,
l'ouverture
a permis effectivement de
d'approvisionner les gens, de les
habituer à un style de vie différent.
Quand tu es à Moscou, tu vois que les
bagnoles en allemande, ça marche hein
quand même hein. Donc c'est pas les
anciennes Trabans ou Bon,
il y en a toujours hein.
Oui, des Trabants. Ouais, c'est conduit
par des occidentaux. Ouais. Enfin bon,
donc c'est pour te dire que si tu veux,
il y a eu aussi cette habitude dans
laquelle évidemment les oligarques ont
le plus profité.
Et donc tu as plusieurs éléments de
fragilité dans la société russe. Le
dernier dont on se préoccupera, c'est
c'est le le vulgum pécus de la
population russe. Celui-là, il est
habitué à ce qu'on lui dise "Non, il y a
plus il y a plus de machin et cetera.
faites la queue. Enfin donc le les
sanctions porteront effet si elles sont
de plus en plus ciblées. Et c'est là que
le travail justement pour tendre le bras
à la City, pour tendre le bras au Crédit
Suisse, pour tendre le bras au Linstein
que tu vas avoir effectivement des
sanctions qui vont dire dans l'entourage
de Poutine, merde, on perd quand même
beaucoup d'argent. Bon, ensuite, tu as
tous les organismes internationaux qu'on
va interdire à la Russie dont le système
Swift qui est quand même un système de
compensation internationale où si
tucèdes pas, tu peux pas te faire
rembourser tes dettes.
Ça fait des années qu'il se préparent à
se faire expulser Swift.
Mais peut-être, mais qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont comme système alternatif à Swift ?
Ils ont
Chinois.
Mais encore une fois, les Chinois, ils
vont pas se priver de swift pour faire
plaisir aux Russes. S'ils les font s'ils
font passer les dettes en Chine pour les
faire passer comme chinoise, tu penses
bien que les tu peux faire confiance aux
Chinois pour se largement se rémunérer
pour ce petit service. Donc c'est pas
c'est pas une situation qui est aussi
simple à gérer que pour les pour la
Russie parce que encore une fois tu as
plusieurs niveau de responsabilité, de
fragilité et évidemment ceux qui sont
les plus atteints, ce seront c'est ceux
qui sont les classes populaires et cela
va leur expliquer que il faut aller
faire la guerre en Ukraine parce que
surtout quand ça commencera à devenir
saignant, qu'il y aura des morts, que
les choses ne se passeront pas,
qu'éventuellement on en on appellera de
nouvelles catégories d'appelés et cetera
et cetera. Question internet, quelle
serait selon lui la sortie de crise
ukrainienne ?
C'est une bonne question. Moi, si tu
veux, il me semble que
Poutine donc utilise le langage de la
force, enfin de la de la menace, bon
de l'intransigence. J'irai jusqu'au bout
de mes objectifs et d'ailleurs je fais
ouvrir les silos de mes forces
nucléaires.
Donc moi à mon sens,
première chose, c'est qu'il faut prendre
en compte le fait que il est l'homme qui
représente le sursaut de dignité de la
Russie. On peut être en désaccord avec
sa méthode mais fondamentalement il
reste pour le moment en tout cas à mon
avis encore une fois je ne suis pas
spécialiste de la Russie je pense qu'il
a une certaine il a encore une certaine
popularité.
Donc première chose sur la posture
militaire, c'est ce qu'on peut décider
les pays de l'OTAN, c'est oninterviendra
pas en Ukraine mais on renforce tous les
pays frontaliers de l'OTAN, donc la
Roumanie, la Bulgarie, la Pologne et
cetera et cetera. C'est à ce moment-là
que tu te rends compte que si tu veux
l'adhésion à l'OTAN n'a pas changé
grand-chose puisque les Polonais veulent
se débarrasser de leur d'or MIG 29 pour
les filer aux Américains en échange de
F16. Donc tu te dis mais qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé depuis la désir de la
Pologne dans l'OTAN ? Donc en fait, on
gesticule, c'est-à-dire on dit "Oui,
mais on enverra des troupes, il y aura
des troupes américaines dans les pays
baltes, il y aura des troupes et cetera
et cetera." Ça c'est pour dire il y a
une ligne qui est un casus béli qu'il ne
faut pas franchir. Deuxième aspect,
c'est le grandir l'arme nucléaire. Bon,
tu tu as entendu le discours de Poutine.
Le nucléaire, le comment dire l'argument
stratégique le plus fort en matière de
nucléaire, c'est de générer de
l'incertitude.
C'est-à-dire
l'autre te menace d'une arme nucléaire,
si tu lui dis "Moi aussi je vais faire
c, je vais faire ça." Tu vois, tu as une
espèce de montée en puissance. Moi, moi
je pense que on sait gesticuler en
matière de nucléaire pour que l'autre
comprenne qu'on a bien compris son
message mais qu'on est prêt à y poster.
Si tu fais sortir un SNLE de la R de
Brest
à l'époque où passe un satellite sovié
russe.
Bon et si les Américains font pareil et
cetera, tu montres que ta posture
nucléaire, elle est prête et en France
c'est un système de d'alerte permanente.
Alors je te coupe.
Ouais. le coup du satellite russe qui
joue au-dessus de Brest
avec un sous-marin qui sort
propre.
Les Russes, ça fait des années qu'ils le
font.
Non,
si ça fait des années qui nous montrent
qu' sont rééquipés, qui passent qui
passent juste à côté de Brest.
Ça fait des années
passons.
Oui, oui, bien sûr. Et alors ?
Et alors ? Ben quand le sous-marin sort,
il est accompagné par une frégate que si
tu veux, on sait qu'il y a des avions
qui vont passer. Donc on attend que
l'avion soit passé pour le faire
plonger. On n'est pas con, on est comme
les autres. Donc si tu veux tout ça
c'est de la gesticulation et donc on est
capable de faire la même gesticulation
pour dire au aux russes que il faut
faire attention. Mais pardon, il y a un
pan qu'il faut y absolument y ajouter,
c'est justement de lancer une grande
initiative diplomatique pour dire il
faut construire une architecture de
sécurité en Europe qui prenne en compte
toutes les variables. Tu vas avoir
évidemment à discuter du statut de
l'Ukraine, tu vas avoir à discuter des
statuts des régions sécessionnistes
russes, c'est-à-dire comment ces gens
peuvent vivre chez eux sans être obligés
de pardon
des régions sécessionnistes
ukrainiennes.
Non, pas seulement ukrainienne. Tu as
aussi la moelle d'Avie, enfin la
transindustrie et cetera. C'est là, tu
as la statue de Kaliningrad qui est
quand même en plein milieu de l'Europe
avec des missiles nucléaires. Donc tu
vois, tu as des tas de sujets qui
donnent le sentiment qu'on veut
construire une véritable architecture de
sécurité et tenir compte de ce que les
Russes pensent. Bon, rappelle-toi quand
même que
la Finlande
était considérée comme un état neutre à
l'époque de l'Est-ouest. On se moquait
d'eux, on parlait de la finisation pour
dire comme si les Finlandais étaient
tous des soumis à l'Union soviétique.
Ils avaient filé une raclé aux Russes
avant guerre. Ils ont toujours ils sont
toujours considérés comme finlandais et
indépendants. Bon, l'Autriche 55, on
négocie le statut de neutralité de
l'Autriche. Bon, donc il y a des moyens
de négocier avec l'autre parti, un
statut de l'Ukraine qui sera un statut
avec garantie de sécurité, garantie des
frontières, tout ce que tu veux. Mais je
veux dire, si tu ne prends pas cette
initiative de lancer une grande volonté
de parler de tous les sujets,
effectivement ta posture militaire n'a
pas d'issue, c'est de faut faire marcher
les deux en même temps. Et faire marcher
les deux en même temps, la question
c'est à quel moment Poutine considérera
que l'opération militaire n'est pas le
l'échec, le succès qu'il aurait
souhaité.
Ça va durer ou ça va pas durer ? Je dire
bah oui, ça va durer bien sûr. Oui.
Sûr ?
Ouais. Ouai. Oui, ça va durer. Ça va
durer parce que tu lances une armée à la
conquête d'un pays,
si ça si ça marche pas, les militaires
sont pas contents. Tu sais, c'est le
mécanisme classique, c'est ce qu'on
appelle le surge en Irak. Si ça marche
pas, c'est parce qu'on a pas assez
d'hommes.
Tout vient, c'était le bon donc toutes
les armées réagissent de la même
manière. Quand on leur donne une mission
mais qu'elles arrivent pas à le remplir,
elle t'explique que c'est parce qu'elles
ont pas les armements, qu'elles ont pas
les effectifs, qu'elles ont pas la
logistique et cetera.
Il y a une espèce de dynamique militaire
qui fonctionne dans toutes les crises et
qui a des chances de fonctionner aussi
sur le sur la la Russie. Maintenant,
est-ce que Poutine sera en mesure de
considérera queil vaut mieux rajouter
des forces, c'est-à-dire aggraver la
crise en Ukraine ou au contraire
profiter d'une opportunité qui serait
donnée par des propositions
diplomatiques ? Je te signale que les
Talibans ont proposé aux Ukrainiens et
aux Russes de discuter la paix.
L'expérience ces agents-là. Pardon ?
Ils ont de l'expérience ?
Ah oui oui, absolument.
Est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train d'ex
d'extrémiser tout le monde ?
Ouai oui. C'est vrai, c'est vrai, c'est
vrai, c'est vrai. Mais c'est pour ça que
je dis qu'il faut pas répliquer au
discours de l'angoisse que que tient de
la pression, tu vois, de la menace que
tient Poutine par un discours de la
menace.
Mais c'est là que joue si tu veux le
complexe militaire ou intellectuel où tu
n'accèdes à un plateau télé que si tu as
des choses à expliquer à faire valoir
disant que tu connais bien Poutine
depuis l'âge de 4 ans, que tu sais que
c'est un homme qui est devenu fou.
Enfin, tu vois, tu tu vas avoir ce genre
d'argumentaire qui correspondent à
l'histérisation du
On a un commentaire sur notre chat qui
est relativement intéressant,
je le lis de Marc de Luxembourg.
Toute la famille de ma femme est russe.
Les premiers jours de la guerre, c'était
Oh non, on ne veut pas la guerre.
Maintenant, c'est OK, tout le monde est
contre nous, on va se défendre et vous
allez le regretter. Résultat, on ne fait
qu'extrémiser tout le monde.
Écoute, ce matin, j'étais j'ai reçu deux
jeunes stagiaires, enfin deux jeunes
chercheur de l'Institut des hautes
études de sécurité intérieure qui
doivent faire des rapports sur les
risques que représente la situation
actuelle pour le ministre de
l'intérieur.
Et moi, je leur dis conseiller au
ministres de recevoir des représentants
de la communauté russe et de la
communauté ukrainienne de France en leur
disant "Je vous considère comme des
citoyens français. Vous avez droit à la
sécurité. Je vous demande de ne pas vous
coltiner les uns contre les autres. Je
protégerai vos lieux symboliques. Je
protègerai les églises basiliques de
pont d'Alma parce que j'estime que ce ce
conflit nous ne sommes pas en conflit
avec la Russie, nous sommes en conflit
avec Poutine. ce geste là serait
symboliquement très fort parce
qu'évidemment tu vas dire
cette guerre ne nous concerne pas
directement et en même temps les gens
qui vivent sur le territoire français
ont droit à la sécurité de leur bien et
de leur de leur lieu symbolique.
Donc c'est vrai faut faut des idées
comme ça quoi pour décrisper justement
et pour sortir de cette espèce
d'hystérie. Moi j'ai des amis russes qui
ont été menacés.
Il y a des restaurants qui s'appellent
la poutine qui se sont fait menacer
aussi et c'est pas de la cuisine russe.
J'ai pas vu. Ah oui, pas ça. Ah non,
mais lesarbés sont très très fréquents à
la surface de la planète. Les types qui
sont capables de croire qu'ils sont à
eux seuls susceptibles de changer une
Est-ce que tu as un autre sujet que tu
veux aborder avec nous ?
Écoute, non, je crois qu'on a fait un
tour d'horizon assez large si tu veux.
Mais
le point sur lesquels je voudrais que
mes amis
Norstream attends un petit euh euh Nord
stream intéressant pas intéressant le
fait qu'on leur coupe le gaz du
bah c'est surtout eux qui nous coupent
le gaz ce signal hein c'est pas nous
hein.
Alors question concrètement comment
fait-on pour pour sortir de tout cela
selon toi qu'on va Zeliski de donner à
Poutine ce qu'il veut crimé donbas et on
en reste là.
On convaince Zeliski de pas adhérer à
l'utant, de pas adhérer à l'Union
européenne.
Ben écoute, c'est ça l'enjeu de cette
grande négociation parce que tu
pass un contrat pour Poutine,
on passe un contrat pour supprimer
Poutine.
Non mais ça le contrat tu peux toujours,
tu vas avoir plein de mecs qui vont te
le proposer, ils arrivent à le faire, ça
c'est autre chose. Mais le
la liste que tu viens de faire est
extremment
les intellectuels médiatiques qui sont
en train de parler de ça. Non.
Ah je savais pas. Peut-être peut-être
mais BHL c'est pas proposé. Donc le
regarde la liste que te donne ton la
personne qui pose la question. On met la
Crimée, la question des régionsniste et
cetera. Le cas de la Crimée est très
intéressant. Pourquoi ? Parce que
bon les frontières de l'Ukraine telles
qu'elles existent aujourd'hui, grosso
modo, c'est celle qui a dessiné Staline
si tu veux après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale. Bon,
l'Ukraine a fourni deux dirigeants
Kchov et Breg l'oublier quand même. Donc
l'apparat, le système politique, le
système communiste si tu veux gommer les
identités nationales.
et Kchov qui en 54 donne la Crimée à
l'Ukraine, région russe. Il y avait pas
de doute hein. Et donc Poutine si tu
veux
fait ce coup de dire "Bon ben, puisque
c'est comme ça, la Crimée, on la
reprend."
Ça veut dire que la Crimée est restée
donc ukrainienne pendant je sais pas 50
ans.
Il fait le coup du référendum.
faire un domme. Regardez ces gens-là,
ils demandent à être russe le coup que
nous avons fait nous avec Mayotte quand
on a fait les référendum au Comor. Les
Comoriens, ils ont voté pour
l'indépendance sauf Mayotte. Et on a dit
"Ah ben dans ce cas-là, Mayotte reste
française." Résultat du match, la plus
grosse maternité de France parce que les
Comoriens viennent tous accoucher à
Mayotte de façon que leurs enfants
puissent demander la nationalité
française après. Donc tu vois comment
même sur une question de chirure de
mouche comme Mayotte,
non ? C'est une île magnifique
mais certainement mais si tu veux
prendre le risque de dire
les maores sont sont les maores sont
absolument adorables. Certainement
certainement mais si tu veux avoir pensé
à cette époque là que dans une dans un
une archipel une île vote pour rester
français on va faire la sécession
organiser la sécession de cette île par
rapport à l'archipel mais je veux dire
ça ça s'appelle les régions
sécessionnistes.
Donc il nous fait le coup à propos de la
Crimée et il est sûr de le gagner parce
qu'il y a 90 % de russes en Crimée. Donc
dans le débat sur la Crimée, il est bien
évident qu'il faudra à un certain moment
reconnaître la légitimité de la
revendication russe sur la Crimée. Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? De la même
façon qu'il faudra un certain moment
reconnaître l'idée que l'Ukraine est
compétente sur son territoire et donc
que les régions sécessionnistes ne
peuvent pas continuer à être
sécessionnistes. Mais tout ça, ça fait
partie d'un panier si tu veux de
négociation pour lequel il faut une
grande conférence internationale. Là,
ils sont à Versailles d'ailleurs
discuter sur des postures communes. Mais
j'espère qu'il va en sortir une grande
initiative diplomatique.
On fera revenir un géopolitologue ou un
historien pour parler de la Chine
Taiïwan plus tard. Est-ce que vous
est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à nous
conseiller ? Tu parles des bouquins en
général ?
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais.
Il y a un bouquin que j'ai commencé à
lire de Sperbert qui s'appelle euh j'ai
j'ai pas l'intitulé en tête mais en gros
c'est dit de euh à l'ope des guerres
justes. Tu vois ce que ça veut dire ? Ça
veut dire toute cette dérive dont j'ai
essayé de te décrire les grandes
caractéristiques qui font qu'aujourd'hui
tu as plein de gens qui te proposent de
faire la guerre parce que la guerre
qu'il te propose est juste.
Il y a trois bouquins. Euh
bon, moi je conseillerais toujours de
lire le la fabrication de l'ennemi, le
bien de bouquin parce que celui-là était
une réflexion sur la comment on fabrique
la guerre.
Et faut que je cherche un troisème
bouquin.
Alors pendant que tu cherches un
troisème bouquin, ton nouveau bouquin,
il sort quand ? Il sort au début du mois
de mai, ça s'appellera euh vendre la
guerre, le complexe militaru industriel
sur des plateaux télé
militar intellectuel.
Mét intellectuel, pardon. Euh les méo
intellectuels les bellissent sur plateau
télé. Et donc le troisème bouquin, le
trisème bouquin et là tu me poses une
colle, tu aurais dû me dire ça un peu
avant parce qu'il y en a plein si tu
veux qui sont extrêmement importants.
C'est pas obligatoirement lié à la
à la guerre si tu veux, mais moi
évidemment les dernières années ont
surtout été occupé sur l'incompréhension
entre le monde arabo mususulman et
l'Occident. Donc
je conseillerai des bouquins ou les
chroniques de que fait cet intellectuel
algérien qui continue à vivre là-bas
alors qu'il est menacé de mort qui fait
des chroniques dans le Point qui
s'appelle
Merde désolé he vraiment là tu
c'est le Covid
c'est le Covid ou Ouais non j'ai vu avec
plaisir queon relançait une initiative
pour faire libérer RF Badaoui
vous connaissez le personnage Badawi
C'est un blogueur saoudien qui s'était
contenté une fois de demander la liberté
de conscience
sur le
Il a reçu combien de coups de fouet lui
?
Il a été condamné à 10 ans de prison et
1000 coups de fouet. 1000 coups de
fouet, c'est-à-dire qu'on le sort
régulièrement de sa prison pour le
fouetter.
Euh,
on se dit que l'Arabie Saoudite est un
pays qui a une justice qui mériterait
largement de passer au-dessus de la
justice russe quand elle arrête Navaldi.
Tu remarqueras que le type est toujours
en prison, qu'on lui a refusé des grâces
et que on n pas réduit ses coups de
fouet. Et j'ai vu que Reporteur sans
frontière et je ne sais quelle autre
organisation ont décidé de relancer la
cause de R Badawi. Quand on est face à
une ignomini comme ça, on se dit il faut
faire un ordre de prioritaire.
Camel Daoud, c'est ça ? Ah, Camel Daoud.
Absolument. Ce type est remarquable.
Type est remarquable. Il vit en Algérie,
il est l'objet d'une fatoi, le menaçant
de mort. Il continue à vivre en Algérie
et il continue à écrire des trucs pour
dire
pourquoi il faut faire des ponts entre
le monde arabusulman et la France quoi.
Alors, je sais pas quels sont ces
derniers bouquins mais enfin
un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable.
Jeis bien faire de la politique mais le
problème c'est que tu vois bien que les
tous les bouchés quoi.
Faites de la politique au sens où
effectivement il y a suffisamment de
problèmes qui j'ai été récemment à une
conférence de
Chaliant de Gérard Chalian qui sort un
bouquin sur sa vie. Bon, j'ai un
chaliant, tu sais, c'est un espèce de
d'itinérant qui a fait tous les conflits
du monde et cetera, qui vraiment est un
grand spécialiste de la guerre, mais il
est fondamentalement pacifiste. Pourquoi
? Parce que il va chez l'autre essayer
de comprendre comment il raisonne. Bon
et euh je me suis dit bon ben
effectivement, il faut lire des bouquins
de chalian mais il en a écrit tellement
que tu te dis.
Et alors, je lui disais un truc que je
trouvais très drôle, c'est que je lui
disais
si on te demandait à toi de partir sur
un lieu de conflit avant,
t'expliquerais comment éviter la guerre.
Je dis mais enfin tu vas créer du
chômage au Pentagone et au ministère de
la défense. Donc quand même fait gaffe
quoi. Voilà,
Pierre connaî ça. Merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]